point I was working on a revision to
sports Bill show you you're doing a lot
from your you know from your original
one I can yeah yeah so I can show you
what I was playing with I've got some of
that back at the house too yeah right so
we we need to tag each other here and
and and do this stuff yeah I was also
working on your part-time teacher Bill a
little bit uh so and of course we need
to get Applebee yeah to in regarding the
certification aspect of that yeah I I I
I did talk to him also about that and
it's a big Financial hit for school
districts in terms of the retirement
system anyone who has a license from the
Department um in terms of the retirement
system is considered a
teacher if there 30 hours or
less this afternoon it's it's a
lunner
and for for our work group this
afternoon
uh that that's
uh
good morning everybody uh we're going to
open up our first hearing for the
education committee our first uh bill on
the dock today is HB
1594 uh this is a bill establishing an
annual review and qualification to
determine eligibility to participate in
the education Freedom accounts program
and I'd like to recognize represent
miler
okay and after you present represent
Myer we'll take your pain
card yes please uh thank you chairman
lad my name is Mel Miler and I represent
maram 9 the gorgeous towns of hopkington
and Bo now I'm presenting uh 1594 for
this morning which is a bill that would
have an annual determination of the
eligibility awards for the freedom
account now the reason why I did this
was because
um my concern was that uh right now once
an individual becomes eligible for the
freedom accounts they stand their for
Life their life uh in school and I
thought that was
wrong uh primarily because most of
ours of which I believe this is since it
has a
350% poverty level eligibility for a
family or for and I begin to think about
well what other poverty programs provide
annual review and I've passed out to you
a thing that I worked with the OS on and
you can see the various programs that in
fact do have an annual
review I want to draw your attention to
the last item on the chart which is the
children's scholarship fund which
currently has about 45% of its students
that are currently getting an annual
review primarily those who have free and
reduced lunch and so my sense was is
that if you have 45% that are already
doing the the program obviously has a uh
system at which they monitor students
Etc uh to do this on an annual review
that we should do this on an annual
basis it's my belief that um as we
looked at the
efas that if you have a a parent for
example who has a child and let's say
the parent's 30 years old and is making
uh you know the 990,000 or so uh
eligibility as their as their salary
increases it seems to me that there
should be some at some point in time
they
basically uh term out if you may uh
their eligibility for that so that's
really the intent of the bill uh it's a
fairly simple concept you can agree or
disagree with it but I think think there
are merits here that when you talk about
families who have to have annual reviews
just to make sure that uh they maintain
their eligibility that that's uh that's
really the intent of this film thank you
thank you very much representative Myer
are questions for representative
Miler not seeing any oh yes
representative
Luna thank you very much Mr chair thank
you very much representative for taking
my question on the um on the handout
that you uh yes did this just come
around for the yes on 1594 um could you
comment again what it what it means in
the the column that says eligibility
period Well I think it means that
annually you families who are in this
particular Center uh column that they
have to be renewed each year
okay so on maintain their maintain their
presence and involvement in the program
so followup thank you so on the on the
last one children's scholarship fund
when it says one year you're meaning
that's what the bill would
propose yes that they would have to do
it on an annual basis thank you so I'm
sorry I didn't get that on the first
time thanks representative McDonald
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Miler I'm looking at the
effective date which must have been an
oversight because it already has passed
but either way is this bill is there any
sort of phase out period so because
there are families who are expecting to
receive this funding in future years are
we just telling them that after when the
date passes are no longer to receive the
funding well they they'll they'll
maintain their eligibility as long as
they maintain that within the
350% of the poverty level so as long as
they maintain that level they'll stay in
the program if they go above that
through a review by the children's
scholarship fund then they would be out
out of that program okay may I have a
followup yes you may and then line 16
there's and be allocated to fund other
efas as removed to this bill could you
address the intent of that if the
funding has already been budgeted for
the EF program EFA program then why
would it return to the education trust
fund as opposed to funding for other
efas I guess I I don't would you state
your question again I'm not quite sure
what it is yes if the funding has
already been budgeted to be put towards
efas then why would it return back to
the trust fund as opposed to funding
another student's EFA account well
there's a there's a budget as I
understand it there's a budgeted amount
there's a
program excuse me there's a budgeted
amount within each budget and so
whatever money is available would be in
from that budget so if somebody doesn't
qualify that just means that whatever
that $5,000 is or whatever that is that
would just stay in that particular fund
okay thank you further questions
voucher thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um you spoke uh
to the um to the idea of renewing
eligibility each year but I didn't
really hear anything speaking to the the
elimination of the rollover from year to
year can you speak a little bit to why
we would be changing that so that funds
are no longer rolling over year to year
but instead uh revert back to the trust
fund well I think if they're if they are
in fact ineligible for the program then
the money would say in the trust
fund follow up thank you if I may just
because I I I want to be certain I'm
reading correctly because I'm not I
don't quite read it the same way so uh
number two program funds and then uh
number
seven which are you represent which are
you referring
to you you mentioned seven and two and
seven I don't know what you're referring
to uh program fund so it's section two
and then uh Roman 7 okay any f en force
and going use funds should roll over
from quarter to quarter but then from
year to year was struck in this
legislation which tells me regardless of
whether the student is remaining
ineligible or becomes ineligible even if
they remain ineligible those funds would
no longer be allowed to roll over from
year to year is that your reading of
this yes thank you further questions
from the committee representative dry
thank you and thank you for taking my
question so just to follow up on that if
if we have if I had a suit who had an
account and for a year we were
ineligible for the fa account that money
would be gone and if we became eligible
again the next year it would be starting
from scratch is that correct I would
assume that would that if if this would
go into effect rules would address that
issue thank you further questions from
the
committee thank you very
much like to call forward David
Trumble
morning Mr chairman good morning and
committee members um I support my name
is David Trumble from the town of wear I
support this bill for a couple reasons
first I think the use of an annual
income eligibility guideline is
consistent with other governmental
programs that are based on income as
representative Myer stated I could not
see any other uh programs that used
income guidelines that didn't have an
annual program in the state it's also
worth noting that the educational
oversight committee majority report REM
recommended an annual review of income
why is this fair this is not about fraud
it's just if a parent one year is
unemployed and the next year is employed
then they're now over that income limit
or if they get promoted or their
self-employment business grow
this is just the way life goes people's
income goes up this bill would only
affect people whose income is above the
350% limit or if the 500% new rule it
would be people above the 500%
rule second is that 350% limit is pretty
high if you compare it to other programs
in the state that use annual income
guidelines for medicate it's
39,900 for low-income energy assistance
it's 60,000 for snap it's
39,000 Child Care scholarship program
for the $5 cost share is 41,000 so the
hund the 109,000 or
156,000 is very high compared to these
other programs what does that mean the
350% limit is the median New Hampshire
income for non-metro New Hampshire the
New Hampshire Finance Authority says the
Statewide median income is
121,000 but for non-metro it's 106,000
so basically what this is saying is that
if you're in the upper half of income if
you started out at some point you were
under the lower half but you move up to
the upper half you're still being
subsidized by the people of the state if
you use the 500% limit and it looks like
that's likely to happen based on last
week's result that's the top 20% of
income in the state the uh New Hampshire
fiscal policy Institute just turned out
a report this year about Granite Staters
with the lowest incomes have the highest
effective tax rates and they tell us
that the
153,00 and above is the top 20% so if if
the 500% rule is going forward basically
what this bill would do is say if you
move into the top 20% the state is no
longer supporting your EFA program and
that doesn't seem unreasonable when
people who are just going into the
$41,000 mark lose their Medicaid they
lose their SNAP benefits and they lose
their child scholarship programs
basically I think it just comes down to
oh the other question is who pays for
this it's the people in the lowerer
income brackets that New Hampshire
fiscal policy Institute said that the
people under 154,000 pay a higher tax
rate than people above it in fact they
said that families in the bottom 20%
have a combined tax rate more than three
times the rate of those in the top 1%
it's a regressive tax state in the state
so really what you're saying to people
who make 40,000 a year is you're going
to finance the education for people who
are now have moved into the $160 to
$200,000 range
that's not fair it's basically just a
question of fairness if your income
rises above the eligibility level then
you should no longer be eligible for the
program we have one set of rules for
low-income programs if your income goes
up you're out this creates a right now
we have a different set of rules for
high incomes even if your income goes up
you get to keep the benefit that's not
fair it's it's disrespectful I believe
to people who are participating in all
of the other Statewide programs thank
you are there any questions from the
committee represent
leus I'm
wondering
public trying to think of how to ask
this
um we're talking about
education and children's
education and the efas are a one of the
recognized methods for getting an
education in the state and I'm wondering
so it should be compared to that rather
than these other things and so I'm
wondering do we means test traditional
public
education thank you representative leus
so two differences with public education
one is under Public Schools we have a
constitutional Duty as a state to
finance those schools that's written in
our constitution it's been made clear by
the Claremont decision as for private
schools they are not mentioned in the
Constitution they're not included in the
Claremont decision we have no obligation
to finance private schools it's an
discretionary expense for the state so
they they're two completely different
systems further questions representative
luckus man every time I go to start to
ask a question my mind goes blank I'm
really sorry
um I'm sorry further questions represent
cordelli thank you thank you for uh
being here again today um I wasn't clear
on what you meant by um funding private
schools I'm not sure who is funding
private schools okay um I should have
said funding the EFA program which uses
which allows people to use the money to
fund private schools but the point I was
simply making was is that the EFA
program is not constitutionally required
of the State of New Hampshire it's a
it's a choice that we've made to have in
this state if tomorrow this the state
had a tremendous Financial shortage and
it eliminated the EFA program that would
be constitutional there's no
constitutional uh block to that
happening but we have to continue to
finance our Public Schools
constitutionally followup um so I assume
you're not saying that the state should
not Institute any programs that are are
not specified in the Constitution am I
correct you're that's not the direction
you're going sorry there was two
negatives in there could you just say
that again represent um I assume you're
not saying that the state should not
Implement any programs that are not
specified in the Constitution I I seem
to hear that in in your comment I I
assume that's not what you mean I I'm
not saying that efas are
unconstitutional and I'm my point today
was not that we should eliminate efas
what my point was just I was asked the
question why why does this not same set
of logic apply to Public Schools why do
we Finance public schools that have
people who are wealthy that attend and I
was trying to distinguish that the
public school is constitutionally
required you heard Andrew Linsky story
about how it came from the you know
Massachusetts Constitution it's part of
the system of government every everybody
in the state benefits from it that's
what we agree as a set of norms if you
have public schools they have to follow
the rules like no discrimination if you
want to set up a private school you're
not bound by any of those rules so
therefore the state is not bound to
finance you but I'm not saying we should
eliminate funds to private schools I'm
just saying if you are going to have a
program like this it should at least
follow the same guidelines we do for
every other income based program in the
state when your income goes above that
number you no longer receive the
benefit represent
so if
we unfund those parents because their
income went a little high you know
bumped up for whatever reason maybe they
have to replace their car and they took
an extra job for a little bit for
whatever reason their income had bumped
up for a little bit and they could no
longer afford whatever it was that they
were doing they would then most likely
revert to the public school and we'd be
paying
$20,000 to educate them rather than
$4,000 to educate them and that's what
you're suggesting so your question is if
they go to the public school it's
actually going to be more expensive and
you think the EFA saves money for the
towns basically yes okay so I I would
like to address that if I might Mr
chairman the question was asked my
conception of that is that that's a
theoretical savings I have never seen
any data that proves that it actually
happen and and I would I would urge you
to go to the convel lawsuit the judge
laid out the expense categories for in
the public schools the number one
expense is the teachers then comes the
facilities then comes excuse me the
other professionals such as your nurse
your guidance counsel your principal and
then you have instructional materials
which is a couple hundred a student
right now we have 4,000 students in the
EFA program 75% of them already go to
private schools 1,000 of them came from
public schools right those are the basic
numbers that we operate on here there's
uh 160 school districts and some almost
500 schools in the state that means that
under the EFA program each school in the
state has had two children who went from
the public school over to a private
school so just think about your local
school it's got 400 children in it two
of them went over to a private school
Under the EFA program does that affect
your teacher salaries the biggest effect
no I mean if you have four classes of
fourth grade each 20 or 25 students
you're not going to lay off a teacher
because two students in the whole school
left you're not going to lay off the
principal or the nurse or the guidance
counselor or the person who meets you at
the desk you still have to fix the roof
you still have to heat the building and
put the lights on the only discretionary
expense that changes is the
instructional materials which is $300
per student so maybe having a child go
over to a private school 3 NFA saves the
town $300 per student but also don't
forget that school now loses the $4,000
in base adequacy although they get back
a couple thousand for the first year or
two it's a little confusing but
basically they they save 300 but they
lose 2,000 so I would say that those two
children have now lost that school money
you would have to have dozens and dozens
and scores of children leaving before
there's any savings but at this point
the program is not saved in my mind
Public Schools a single
dollar thank you very much are there
further questions from the committee
represent
luno thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you very much uh Mr Trumble for uh
for joining us this morning um just
based on what you're you're talking
about now and students that that exit
their public school and that under
certain conditions might return to their
public school um are are we seeing as as
now that we've got sort of three years
of data that are starting to come out um
on the uh the the education Freedom C
program are we seeing students that may
have exited their Public School in one
year then returning back to their public
school after another after a year of
maybe being out with an EFA it's really
unclear uh there's another category of
people who students who are kind of lost
in the numbers who they don't know what
happened to them there they went to a
private school but then they got lost
and there was somebody who testified
that somebody from this from the uh EFA
program was a number keeper of that
explained that there's some that they
don't know about it's it's it's it's
some percentage I don't know I mean
maybe they graduated maybe they dropped
out maybe they returned back to to
public school I do know from just
reading about how EFA type programs or
voucher type programs whatever they're
called different things around the
country many parents especially special
ed parents are used to a public school
where you get an e you get an IEP and
everything that's in that you have a
right to then they go to a a through a
voucher program in other states which
what they're called in those States
voucher programs they don't know what
they're getting into they don't realize
that they're giving up their their
rights they they have to sign away their
their Federal rights they get to the
private school and find out that they
have one special educator who does all
the special ed for the building and may
not be trained in their child's and then
they start looking for other private
schools and maybe they go back to the
public school so I don't have the
numbers that's one of the basic problems
with this program is it keeps expanding
but we don't have a really good grip on
how it's working so I don't know but I
uh I wish I could give you an answer
thank you further questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much thank you Mr chairman I have no
more cards on this so I'm going to close
this hearing down and we'll start the
other up in five
minutes
okay we're going to go ahead with the
next hearing the next hearing on the
dock is
1287 this is an act relative to the
definition of the term evidence-based
within public education welcome
representative beler thank you Mr chair
and members of the committee good
morning this bill um is primarily about
directing this state and our education
not the curriculum but the methods by
which we use educate to be rooted in a
in a properly defined
scientific process so first imagine the
two following questions that each
generate data the first question is this
program when instituted demonstrates on
average a 10% increase in standardized
test scores apologies that's not a
question but it's a statement of fact
that contains data the second question
true or false I feel like students are
more capable of Performing after doing
this program
both of those items generate data but
the data they generate is not
equal first science operates by
attempting to falsify a claim the more
attempts to falsify a claim that a claim
survives the higher degree of certitude
we can have that the claim is
true the second question posed based in
feelings and subjectivity
is fundamentally not
falsifiable therefore it cannot be said
to represent real good
science far too often in the history of
education have we relied on this second
type of
data this has resulted in the adoption
of suboptimal methods suboptimal
outcomes and significant Wast in time
and money
there is no need for us to continue to
do this all across this nation and
across this world colleges of education
and other related fields are constantly
pushing out studies peer reviewed good
science studies demonstrating methods
that can be efficacious or disproving
methods but saying that oh absolutely
actually this doesn't work we find that
out all the
time if we want to improve
outcomes and do the best by our students
we must eliminate
nonscience and pseudo science-based data
from our evaluations of the methodology
being
used we should only be using objective
verifiable data based on falsifiable
hypotheses now to the cost of
this this shouldn't cost much of
anything to our state or to our local
subdivisions in this in this
state this law allows for localities and
those adopting these pedagogical methods
to demand of the providers of textbooks
and other such methods that they furnish
them with the studies that they relied
upon when creating their
products in other words the textbook
providers and others should already have
this data they already should have used
it when they put their text together all
we ask them to do is furnish it to us
the state and or those adopting this so
they can in turn furnish this to the
public this is a hugely necessary item
transparency is Paramount this is the
way science works it science works by
continually attempting to falsify
information and claims by putting this
information out publicly it allows
parents it allows teachers and allows
experts in various Fields all over the
country and all over the world to look
at the studies we're relying upon and
say hey this is a good study or maybe
it's not and they can raise a concern
with
it and according to this basic logic if
the methods being utilized are in fact
efficacious if they work they should be
no problem whatsoever to identify two or
more studies from educational related
fields
that actually say yeah this we tried to
falsify this concept and we couldn't so
it's a good
concept
further we will be throwing a wrench
into the occasional bad
habits of major education corporations
and those sometimes producing the
textbooks of making frequent
changes that they might update their
textbooks to sell more textbooks and
more new classes it's been a longterm
problem within the field of Education
this concept of chasing fads and we
would by doing this and relying on good
science take away the necessity or the
even ability to constantly update things
based on new unproven
things
finally this has no direct bearing on
the individual teacher or classroom that
was not the intent of this bill that
bird the teacher with anything
whatsoever it is specifically written to
this that it shall not be enforced at
that level this is all about those
people those organizations such as the
the doe and local school boards who are
adopting the pedagogical methods that
are being pushed into the
classrooms it does bind the state
accepting higher education and their
freedom of Education to conform to this
proper definition of the term
evidence-based
and it does so to eliminate any
possibility of misuse of the term that
could see false scientific Concepts
being legitimized under the banner of
evidence-based and that's what it does
I'd be happy to take questions thank you
very much other questions from the
committee represent cordelli thank you
um whose evidence are you relying on and
who's evaluating that
evidence I I assume you mean if if the
bill were were to pass whose evidence
would we be relying upon we would be
relying upon the evidence um produced by
professional journals professional
colleges in order to the the the persons
who uh actually do design studies the
ones they're typically involved in peer
review though they don't necessarily
have to be um and they would that would
be the data and evidence we would rely
upon for pedagogical
methods yes um uh a couple of months ago
during the presidential c campaign uh
there was a little um uh discussion
about the uh causes of the Civil
War um
what um and different
viewpoints um what evidence would you
rely on um for discussion in uh
curriculum or classroom as to the causes
of the Civil War whose evidence would
that be relied on well thank you for the
question but this bill doesn't actually
speak to that because that would be a
curriculum matter and this is purely
dealing with pedagogical methods not not
curriculum or or what is true or false
in curriculum it's a matter of how
things are to be taught in terms of
efficacy of methods one last question
yeah thank you um last year I had a bill
related to
literacy and for decades we relied on um
the U methods uh outlined in terms of
teaching reading by Lucy ckins and um
others um who agreed with her um methods
um and that was evidence-based it was
written up in the journals Columbia uh
University had um a unit um specifically
related to that in terms of uh
instruction but that was disprove so
that was evidence
based so now after
Decades of research and including brain
studies on how students learn to read um
there is new
evidence um the science of reading if
you will um that um has been objected to
by some um so in terms of literacy what
evidence should we rely on um Lucy cins
evidence or um other evidence that has
been gathered over the past couple of
decades thank you for that and that that
really highlights some of the importance
of of what I'm talking to in this bill
so we we have to understand that there
is no such thing as a perfect science we
don't have perfect information in this
world about really anything it's about
trying to improve our understanding of
things over time and as such we do have
to recognize that science because it is
constantly testing falsifiable claims
may eventually falsify a claim which
means the science itself can
legitimately change that's something
that can happen which is a matter that
is addressed in this bill because it
it's it's not about making the perfect
the enemy of the good it's about saying
that we should be doing the best we can
even though it's not going to be perfect
and how do we identify the best at any
given time that we can do and I think
that's the the angle that you're
speaking to as well in this and and
that's a a approach I would report to
good objective scientific evidence being
used in pedagogical
methods I I do have a question sort a
little bit followup to where repesent
Celli was coming from can evidence-based
as you define that be based upon
historical research that is premised
upon studying and understanding causes
and effects of trends that occurred in
the past to anticipate where we're going
in the
future I think I have an idea of what
you're speaking to um so this bill in
terms of evidence-based excuse me it
would allow the consideration of any
evidence-based so a properly designed
study so a historical study could be
included um
however the bill does leave the
obviously can't fix everything the bill
does leave the possibility that you
could address old science and ignore
some new science but that's why the
transparency is so important it's
because people can look at this parents
whoever can look at this and say hey
this is this is old son this is an old
study and we have newer studies that
actually have falsified that claim in
the meantime so it's it's something that
can be updated and it can be updated
according to a legitimate objective
measurement as opposed to updating
constantly
based on more subjective matters which
are not an optimal way to do things
thank you representative
Woodcock good morning thank you chairman
L Rob uh I'm thinking about the
practicality okay um I'm looking at Mich
on your uh particularly in respect to
line 14 and 15 not sort the line but the
the inference if we're talking about um
including educator
training okay um I'm thinking about the
different schools of philosophy and the
different schools of
training uh that folks come from we have
in this committee seven or eight n
former teachers may have been trained at
seven eight nine different colleges some
private some Catholic some maybe Greek
some public I mean so they have
different philosophies some more
Socratic you know what they thinking so
I don't understand understand how we're
going to be able from a practical
standpoint uh where it comes to
including educator training uh how we
could make this applicable at work sure
thank you uh that's a very important
point so this doesn't seek to address
historical issues with people having
been trained in different places and
having different philosophies and in
fact there's plenty of room within this
for different philosophies to exist
because I do know for a fact that these
different philosophical doctrines from
education are individually and
separately producing their own
peer-reviewed studies
so if they want to be able to continue
in that same manner all they would have
to do is is identify the for instance
the College of Education that is
teaching this philosophy we just have to
identify two or more studies that are
proper peer review or they don't even
have to be peer review but they have to
be properly properly well-designed
studies that justify that methodology of
of of approach and I I mean there's more
than one way to skin a cat there's more
more than one way to teach a child so
you're going to have differences of
approaches that can be separately
verified to be be effective and that
that is all free to exist perfectly fine
under
here thank you sir um to the same
extent how in the practicality piece of
this
thing how are we going to regulate that
the nine different schools those folks
around this room went to are going to
participate in this I go to the if I go
Ohio State or uccla or B cookman and I
come here we can't ensure all those
three school and all of are going to
provide education evidencebased
education pedagogy
instruction correct yes this this has no
ability we have no ability to regulate
anything that's happening out of state
if somebody learned methods that are not
optimal that that that don't stand up to
criticism and study and they come here
there wouldn't be any immediate uh
effect to this but what we can control
is our continuing education of Educators
that occurs in the state and to make
sure that that continuing education does
do occur along lines that are actually
based on good objective data sets that
would be that last last thing yes thank
you so that would be the profession
development once this The Faculty are on
board in different schools in New
Hampshire but it wouldn't really be the
education training would be the
professional development continued yes
okay thank you thank you chairman lad
represent
leus thank you thank you for taking my
question you use the term
reproducibility
and I'm wondering if you can Define that
is that
reproducible in the same circumstances
or is that reproducible say in this case
across districts across ages across
types of kids Etc thank you for that
that's a very important point to clarify
so reproducibility in this is actually
talking about the scientific
reproducibility of studies meaning that
if you do you conduct a study on a
methodology and it demonstrates okay
that we have this positive out outc come
this positive effect it we did not
falsify a truth claim and then another
study is necessary this is why I've
written this requires two or more
studies from education or related
fields another study then is done that
confirms that and that is
reproducibility the ability to confirm
the same result in in in repeatable
studies thank you represent
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question so I feel like I'm hearing a
conflict between some of what you're
stating and some of the language in the
bill so I would hope you can clarify
sure on line seven and8 it reads the
general court believes that while peer
review of studies has uses including
evaluating the proper design of studies
peer review alone has no weight in
evaluating or falsifying claims but I
believe I've just heard you validate the
usefulness of peer review multiple times
so correct I don't understand uh so So
within the scientific process what peer
review is primarily good for and what it
was primarily originally intended for is
the ability of persons who have
expertise in these sorts of data and and
studies to determine if the study itself
is properly designed to meet and produce
the criteria the kind of data that we
want to see but when it comes to whether
something is true or false peer review
has no no effect on whether something is
actually true or false it stands alone
as is as a true item or a false item and
that's all this is
saying further further questions yes you
have a followup to
that thank
you
so since peer
review could and
does validate or invalidate study
design how is that not a credible piece
of what the results of that study are I
mean it if it didn't pass muster for
peer review then you don't trust the
results of the study I I think we're
we're crossing on so what I'm what I'm
referring to is purely an
epistemological issue so how do we
verify a truth claim and the fact is
something is either true or it's not
depending on and that doesn't matter
what people say about it so in that
regard peer review the fact that certain
people think it's true or false doesn't
actually affect whether or not it is
actually true or false but they are
useful because they have expertise in
this area for helping to guide us in our
decision-
making further questions from the
committee representative dry thank you
and thank you for taking this question
can you maybe illustrate for us what the
local school districts and Department
making publicly available the scientific
studies they relied on would look like
sure I and I left it kind of open-ended
so they could pursue different ways of
doing this it could be a matter of they
have it available and upon request they
will provide it such as something like
under 91a would be or they could choose
to publish this kind of stuff to a
website and say hey this is the uh the
me methodology we're using and this is
this the two or more studies that that
demonstrate the efficacy of this
technique further questions from the
committee representative Tanner okay
thank you I actually have two questions
but they're kind of related one um is
whether this is based on um legislation
in other states and part of it National
legislation and which standardized test
uh were you referring to when you said
PE people do better in scientific um
with your methodology rather than um
what's currently being
offered um so the the first one um I
referred to nothing when I created this
this was from scratch from scratch from
scratch um on the second question could
you rephrase it because I'm not sure I
probably you referenced in the beginning
that uh you have found that in
standardized tests students that are
exposed to this do better than the the
common practice and I'm thinking we
don't do this um and so it isn't our
standardized tests in New Hampshire so
which standardized tests are you looking
at thank you so I I think there was a
bit of a misunderstanding on that that
that's probably my fault I didn't speak
it appropriately so I was simply
providing two hypothetical examples to
demonstrate two different types of data
one type of data is objective data uh an
improvement and standardized test scores
that can be documented the other type is
subjective data based on a true or false
I feel like students are more capable um
as of right now the term evidence base
would treat those two data sets
identically with equal weight it's my
contention that that second data set
based in subjectivity should not be
given the weight of an objective data
set such as a demonstrated increase in
test scores so it's hypothetical I'm not
referring to anything real that is
actually happening it's just to
demonstrate the difference between those
two types of
data thank followup just to make sure
I'm clear on this because when you
started out your introduction said that
students do better on standardized tests
when they're exposed to this
evidence-based um scient in Education
Act rather than what they do presently
and I'm just asking what standardized
test did you base that on and where did
it come from thank you just to clarify I
did not in fact say that what I said was
imagine the two following questions that
generate data I did not claim that this
was based on any any program they were
purely
hypotheticals representative
Ford thank you Mr chair I'd like like to
ask you a question about verifiable
through history or things like that I
realize that we're talking about
post Haw Ergo propter Haw which is
commonly argued this happened but
therefore that happened and it's proven
to be pretty well false it didn't
necessarily cause and so you're when you
get down to arguing causality I.E truth
or some version of
Truth what do you run into when you're
as in the argument you talked about the
cause of the Civil War that was recently
and can you make that case based
on the subject of slavery did not appear
in the public argument here's the
document of the arguments sure because
until Abraham Lincoln introduced it at a
certain point to sway the argument as he
admitted sure so first let let me be
very clear that this bill does not touch
kurriculum it only touches pedagogical
methods so it would not be evaluated or
looking at things like the cause of the
Civil War or other items that would be
covered within curriculum it would only
be looking at like well what's the most
effective method to teach kids to read
or to do math and is this method can we
demonstrate here's a here's a truth
claim the truth claim is this method of
teaching math uh is an improvement over
our current setup so we evaluate that
truth claim based on okay let's put it
to a study let's try this method and
let's take some objective measurements
from it look at test scores let's look
at other performance metrics and say
okay can we can we demonstrate that this
truth claim is false if we can't
demonstrate it's false and the more
often we test it and can't demonstrate
that it's false the more likely it is to
be true so we would Institute that
method based on these well-designed
scientific studies to improve things
like math education and reading
education but has nothing to do with
curriculum or what students are being
taught representative
cascaden uh thank you Mr chair thank you
for um taking my question I'm wondering
I mean I don't dispute that
evidence-based methods should be applied
must be applied um I'm wondering if you
have a specific example as
to where or what was implemented that
was not
evidence-based um and I'll tell you what
the reality is in the public school
setting as a principal for over 20 years
I had a lot of responsibility on
purchasing materials changing methods
strategies techniques based on evidence
I mean that is a must I mean I agree
with you that um and in particular
because we're spending the taxpayers
money that better be all out on the
table um but sometimes we have vetted
programs or methods for well over a year
before we've actually jumped and
Incorporated so just wanted you to know
the reality is that sometimes it takes
one two 3 years to change a method or a
technique sure because you're vetting
that evidence so I I'm questioning do
you have a specific example that I can
understand why there's a need for this
sure thank you thank you so I'll deal
with that backwards forward so um to
start the the the issue is being able to
properly evaluate that evidence and what
the evidence means and where it's coming
from and that is why in my opinion is so
important to differentiate data sets
between subjective and objective
measures because I do know and i' I've
seen some of the surveys that are
currently being done in schools as far
as asking teachers to evaluate like how
this program is working in terms and
they will ask questions like do you
think this program is working better
than your previous program um and they
will rely to significant degree they
will put a significant amount of weight
on those kind of responses um in
comparison to things like well well is
this reflected in objective standards
such as test scores graduation rates and
any other objective metric can be that
can be pulled out of this in order to
evaluate it um so I think there is a
real problem that is happening currently
where there is too much subjective data
being collected and being utilized in
determining how efficacious these
various methods are and when it comes to
specifics all I think we have to do is
look at the history of um teaching math
or teaching reading that we have in fact
jumped into into certain areas where we
thought things were going to be good and
then later those truth claims were
falsified and we found out actually
that's not so good maybe it's not ideal
so what this does and I can't say it's
going to fix everything all the time
nothing's going to be perfect but what
it would do is by making sure we utilize
objective measures instead of subjective
we are aiming toward the direction of
reality itself instead of what people's
perceptions might be and I think that
elimin Ates a lot of potential for bias
and a lot of potential for other issues
that
happen yes so you're referring to
surveys in terms of like School climates
just an example of one I'm I'm not so if
if students completed a survey about
school
climate um and it meant that okay let's
um let's do something about wherever the
deficit is that if it's not
evidence-based that you can't make that
change I not exactly sure how you would
Define School climate because this is
really just referring to pedagogical
methods so it's not in academics in
academics so it's not it's not looking
at like well how do I feel about this
thing I mean you can collect that kind
of data it just can't be used to back up
a pedagogical
method represent
cordelli thank you first um don't
teachers um routinely on a day-to-day
basis change instructional methods
depending on the situation depending on
the student um and those aren't
necessarily evidencebased they're based
on student need so I'm not sure how a
teacher would specify what they're doing
is evidence-based thank you and they
would not have to because it is it is
explicitly written to this legislation
that it does not apply at the level of
the individual teacher or individual
classroom it is only for those school
boards and doe and others who are
adopting more broad brush these
pedagogical methods yes um several years
ago um the state switched kindergarten
instruction from a more academic based
model to a play-based
instruction and uh I I know there was
great debate about that for several
years and um many people brought forward
evidence about test scores you know once
they reached a greater um uh grade
levels uh with the academic instruction
um focus on kindergarten but others
brought forward studies um about play
based instruction and outcomes so
who's who's I go back to the question
whose evidence do you rely on when there
are conflicting studies that that's an
excellent question and this this bill is
not designed to arbitrate between what
evidence-based methods are utilized it
is just to limit the overall scope of
what we're looking at to objective
measures instead of subjective ones so
we know that when we are deciding what
evidence-based measures to implement and
utilize that at least we're looking at
objective measures and things that are
connected to reality and have been
studied as opposed to things that are
collecting surveys on how do you feel
about this how this
works well we're getting really per name
one more question that's we're going to
call it quits
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
another
question I would like to hear why the
bill only addresses this uh approach in
public education and not everywhere that
our tax dollars support
education that was purely a matter of
where it seems to me we have the most
obvious jurisdiction in regulating and I
didn't want to overstep with
this thank you very much um thank you
very much we're g to call quits on the
questions at this point and I'd like to
go on with the other people that have
submitted pink cards here um like to
invite Emma
svy good morning uh representative vad
and members of the committee my name is
Emma Sven I the children's Behavioral
Health policy coordinator at new Futures
new Futures is a nonprofit nonpartisan
organization that solves problems
through part uh policy change we're here
um in opposition to 128 House Bill 1287
um just out of fear of some unending
consequences to the bill I think um
while we understand the the commendable
um intent behind the bill I think there
are some practices that are in schools
already under a the phrase
evidence-based practice that could be
Exempted then from this definition
that's being put forth um and
furthermore removing the phrase peer
studied or removing the regard to peer
studied um can reduce the uh like
legitimacy of studies so to speak um
peer reviewed is an important piece of
having a well-designed study um and it
makes a study what what it is um it
makes a study rep replicable or um
reliable so um there's been a lot of
conversation up at the higher level um
the unintended consequences we're
foreseeing are uh in regard to social
emotional learning um and the
multi-tiered system of support or
mtssb um these are uh Frameworks that
schools and school districts Implement
through evidence-based practices so um
for social emotional learning so to
speak that's a framework and the school
will Implement an evidence-based
practice to implement social emotional
learning so as we were all here last
week um for the uh bill on social
emotional learning the school districts
will Implement um you know classes or or
some type of uh learning for students to
um have that social emotional learning
component to their education um this
evidence-based
is defined um in many places but it is
pertaining to um or derived from
informed and informed by objective
science most commonly educational
research or the metrics of schools
teachers that sort of thing so it is
already defined in data and in fact
there is a federal statute the um educ
every student succeeds act that defines
evidence-based as requiring studies um
and it has a separate definition um and
explains how schools can select their
evidence-based practices already from
various levels or tiers of
evidence-based practices that are
defined by different studies and study
types that definition differs slightly
from the definition included in this
bill in a way that I think could exclude
some of the evidence-based practices
that are already successfully being
implemented in schools and that we're
seeing are working well
um right now our students are suffering
from mental health consequences they
based on the ybs are having um High
rates of depression anxiety suicidal
ideation and behaviors um right now it
would be really detrimental to our
students to change or add a definition
unnecessarily that could take away those
practices that are already being
implemented and implemented with success
um so for those reasons uh new features
is opposed to this bill I'm happy to
take questions I know that this is um
kind of a a bill that touches more than
just social emotional learning so I'm
happy to take questions as they pertain
Tok area questions from the committee
represent cordelli thank you thank you
for being here um so correct me if I'm
wrong but I I think you're I heard you
say that social emotional learning was
evidence-based so the framework is uh
like a a theory so to speak and then the
evidence-based is the method it's
delivered to students so um there can be
various uh practices so to speak that
are evidence-based that are delivered to
schools and that's how schools do it and
do it
successfully further questions from the
committee represent Dr thank you and
thank you just kind of follow up on that
um that sounds to me that that's more
like the curricul part which he said
wasn't affected by the
evidence-based so that's where it gets a
little confusing with this bill as well
and why it's a
little I think an unintended consequence
um that we're just concerned about so
the curriculum piece yes there are
schools that have set curriculum for
seal that's Exempted by this bill but
there are other pieces of seal that are
just embedded in our day-to-day schools
and the way that people administer
education
um I'm not an educator but um for my
understanding um seal is delivered
through you know encouraging students to
work together um on the playground and
not be bullies or something like that so
um that type of non-curriculum
learning is also happening and I believe
would be looped in on this definition
yes okay and I think that that that kind
of lends to representative cordell's
question about whether teachers can
change their their method of dealing
with particular students so it seems to
me like that falls under that category
more than
pedagogy un absolutely so yes uh that
was not a great example of exactly
um let me back up so yes teachers are
Exempted as you mentioned but school
districts are implementing seal on a
districtwide level and so that
districtwide level is what would not be
Exempted by this bill and that's where
our concern is further questions from
the committee thank you very much thank
you uh we have a card from
Elizabeth
scrutin have your children's trust yes
good morning you um thank you chair and
members of the committee I'm Liz scrutin
I work at New Hampshire children trust
who is the New Hampshire lead Agency on
the prevention of child abuse and
neglect um and today I'm adding my voice
in opposition to the proposed science
and education bill um particularly that
definition of the evidence base that
everybody has been referring to um
echoing what Emma said um while the
intention of this bill is really
commendable uh in seeking to ensure the
quality
pedological uh methods the
implementation as outlined is a little
flawed and potentially harmful uh to the
very students it aims to serve um as we
consider the implications of this bill
um it's essential to recognize that
foundational importance of the social
emotional competence in children um the
streng strength thing of families
approach which is implemented in some
schools um is one of those peer-reviewed
processes um where it does have the
research behind it but is not considered
evidence-based um but esteemed
institutions such as the American
Academy of Pediatrics Annie Casey
Foundation Center of child um for
Harvard University all unders score that
um we know that research is highlighting
that promoting social and emotional
confidence in a child's developmental
Years also makes measurable impact on
families um by fostering these
relationships by giving the more uh
personalized approach to social
emotional learning we see that family
stressors also come off of this because
we know that um social emotional
competence can play such a role in a
child's behaviors in and out of
school uh so by narrowly defining this
evidence-based prti practice this bill
really undermines the creation of
supporting learning environments which
are named in the cdc's essentials for
childhood as a strategy of decreasing
the risk of child abuse and
neglect um so in conclusion while
promoting evidence-based practices is
commendable that this act fails to
consider that holistic nature of Child
Development are there any questions from
the
committee now see thank you very much
thank you I have no further cards on
this bill so I will close the hearing
for
1287 I if anybody has written testimony
could you please submit that so we can
put it into the record please if you
have written
testimony you're
welcome okay the next bill for this
morning is
1453 Rel to degree granting authority of
certain institutions of higher education
1453 represent luno welcome Mr chair
thank you very much and I will uh have a
card for you I was question my testimony
so uh for the record my name is Dave
luno um representing the people of
Hopman B and uh folks all across the
state so I'm here to introduce House
Bill
1453 uh and I'll get ahead of any
questions I I wrote this bill all on my
own it's not based on any national
framework or uh or or prescription so um
and um and in the basically in the
nutshell um 1453 establishes a minimum
standard for uh for the state's higher
education commission which is part of
our Department of Education uh a minimum
standard for uh for approving uh
institutions of higher education for
degree granting Authority and um and
occasionally this committee will hear uh
from um uh uh from new institutions of
higher education that are interested in
operating inside the state of New
Hampshire and conferring degrees upon
its graduates um and um and that's
something that is uh is subject to to
both uh our approval as a legislature
and uh and and subject to the high
education commission's recommendation uh
for approval so again this bill is
establishing just uh just a minimum deck
for uh for what that uh entails so um so
let me just sort of run through what uh
what that means um and how the bill
accomplishes that unfortunately the uh
the provision in law in RSA 292 colon
8h is not contained in our um in our law
books um and I suspect it may be because
it what has not been amended in the last
uh in the last year but uh but it's a
pretty straightforward section of Law
and and I'll just sort of you know give
you a little context of it right now the
section applies to all education
institutions within the state granting
degrees or seeking to do so except the
following a any institution now granting
degrees which has been in continuous
operation since before
1773 we know what that is
yeah that's one so so uh and um and the
second one is institutions of the
University system of New Hampshire and
institutions of the community college
system of New Hampshire so uh so
basically the section of law applies to
any other um
U private uh organization that's uh
that's seeking to become operated as a
as a Institute of high Ed in the state
of New Hampshire and conferred degrees
um no Institute no educational
institution shall Grant degrees unless
approved by the higher education
commission and authorized by name to do
so by an act of the legislature so
that's what I was just talking about
there's two parts of the process
recommendation by the department of Ed's
higher education commission and action
upon the
legislature and what the bill before you
does is it adds a a paragraph to what I
just read that says any institution
approved by their higher educ education
commission under paragraph two what I
just read shall be a nonprofit
organization exempt from income tax
under 501c3 501c3 IRS um statute so
that's the first part number two
complies with all provisions of the
institutional eligibility standards of
the higher education of act 1965 those
are civil civil rights protections that
were put in place at the federal level
and in particular con contain things
like title 4 with which is um which is
uh federally back student loans and
Title 9 which is um uh which is fairness
um and U and then the third piece is
complies with all applicable state and
federal anti-discrimination laws so and
um and the um the this language here was
uh was run by both the community college
and the university system uh Chad
Pimentel from who's the um the um
the the
uh the the the council for the
University system of New Hampshire uh
suggested that we put all applicable
state and federal anti-discrimination
laws in there using all applicable in
there so uh so which we have which we
have done so so this has been reviewed
so so these three things standards are
important standards are important to the
state of New Hampshire we listen to
standards we look at standards all the
time represent beler was just here
talking about some uh some standards
when it comes to um to to uh
evidence-based practices standards are
important civil rights are
important currently it's not something
that's required uh by the higher
education commission or by the
legislature when uh when recommending uh
the approval of an Institute of of
higher education for degree granting
Authority in the state civil rights are
important and anti-discrimination is
important we hear that from all of us we
hear that it's not a partisan issue
uh but it's not something that's
currently contained in in the statute so
these are the three things this bill
puts in making sure that we're 501c3
nonprofit make sure that we comply with
the federal Higher Education Act and
number three that all applicable federal
and state anti-discrimination laws are
followed all before the higher education
commission can recommend a u uh a new
College to do business in the state and
have degree granting Authority um and
and there's also some rationale behind
behind these three not not that we need
it beyond what uh what are clearly
priorities uh that we that we all share
in the state but um but you know based
on you know Common trends that we've
seen in other states that uh that do
have um uh
for-profit uh colleges and uh and of
course the very very few
colleges and universities um that do not
follow the federal Higher Education Act
um for civil rights protections but
common trends that that we see in other
states that uh that do um uh have these
colleges operating in their states high
cost and debt burden debt burden with
students uh particularly a heavy
Reliance on uh on student loans when
attending for-profit colleges low
graduation rates compared to public and
for-profit institutions so low
graduation rates aren't things that are
good for our students they're not
they're not it's not something that's
good for our economy it's not something
that's good for for our Workforce or um
or or degree attainment so uh so looking
out to avoid that Pitfall um Quality
concerns uh lack of accreditation and uh
We've SE other states have seen that
that the the accreditation standards for
some colleges particularly for-profit
colleges
uh may be uh may be lacking or that
these colleges because they have
for-profit motivations uh limit
resources for students so not good
things particularly uh in light of you
know a lot of the testimony we've be
been hearing on other bills and um and
then I guess finally aggressive
marketing tactics that uh that some
Institutes of higher education are
employing and uh having sort of
deceptive marketing schemes that make uh
prospective students feel that they're
going to be able to to get a job quick
get rich quick something like that uh
without really having to put the time
into it so so you know I'm sure there's
exceptions to every rule but um but
these are the trends that we're seeing
these are the the you know sort of the
the standards that I think are important
to all of us and U and all 14536 to do
is set some sort of quality at deck for
um for the higher education to uh to to
work from when recommending um
Institutes of higher education have
degree granting Authority within the
state with that I'll happy to take some
questions thank you very much I I'd like
to ask a question just for clarification
here uh when I'm looking at the bill
analysis on the front page it's saying
the higher education
commission uh will be granting Authority
actually the approve uh to be organized
as nonprofit
organizations and as I see nonprofit
organizations rather
than profit going out to
investors on the other side of the coin
the profit or the balance sheet if there
is any Revenue that's in in beyond their
operating needs it plows back into the
organization uh the university how's
this going to impact a uh a for-profit
such as SN well for-profit SN is not a
for-profit
well it it's it's a nonprofit I don't
believe that's not what they're saying
on the web I don't believe we have any
for-profit Institutes of higher
education in New
Hampshire I mean for-profit or I mean
there are there are some you know
nationally out there I don't believe sou
I don't know if somebody can look it up
uh quickly on this I don't believe
Southern New Hampshire University is a
for-profit school it's a private
nonprofit
I saw I thought no no but
I no yeah um but that's why I say
clarification yeah I need clarification
yeah yeah no I I I and I could be wrong
on that but uh but my understanding is
that New Hampshire does not have have
any instit higher education institutions
with degree granting Authority that are
for-profit institutions
um okay for questions represent
Damon and this is up
toser
right
correct further questions represent mil
thank you m thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative luno for bringing
this forward I think in the 12 years
I've been on this committee we may have
had maybe three or four uh issues come
before this committee so could you for
the for you for the edification of the
committee could you outline exactly the
role that the higher education
commission plays in receiving
applications and what's the process of
it to ultimately come before the uh
legislature so thank you very much for
the question it's it's been a little bit
time since I think we've had the higher
education uh commission here um this
committee actually did um did approve uh
an organization down in Nashua u a u a a
a a private
nonprofit uh Aviation management I
believe it was an aviation management
company and um and the higher education
commission does look at the um the
ability for that organization to serve
its students meet the students needs uh
sustainability
accreditation
um I'm sure there are several other
factors uh involved in that there's um
there's there are uh several people that
uh that are on the higher education
commission who uh who we've all seen in
this committee uh whether they're
testifying on those uh bills uh for
higher education or they may be
testifying on other bills but these
people have a lot lot of experience
they've been um you know former
chancellors of um of community college
system uh former uh College presidents
uh within the um the university system
and the community college system so so
so I think the higher education
commission does have have uh good good
internal standards that they uh that
they look for but uh but as far as I can
tell based on on the law set forth in 2
92h uh which which provides the
barebones criteria for rec for approval
of degree granting Authority the
legislature does not set a floor a
statutory floor for this and um and
adding these these three areas being a
nonprofit combin uh complying with the
Higher Education Act and complying with
federal and state uh applicable federal
and state um anti-discrimination laws
would uh would be a reasonable uh hard
deck to uh for the legislature to set
further questions representa
Tanner thank you just in your response
to uh SN um it says SN is a nonprofit
501c3 institution and according to the
National Center for educational
statistics students who pursue their
bachelor's degree at private nonprofit
institutions experience much higher
graduation rates than their counterparts
at for profit schools
so the concern that I did have have on
that is the analysis says to be
organized as a nonprofit organization
the analysis doesn't mention any of the
501c3 at all the analysis is often times
seen as an intent and the intent here
would be nonprofit
organization well it but the the the
bill does require I get it the title
though I'm I'm speaking to the analysis
on the bill I think it's consistent
no I'm not gonna no no no no that's yeah
represent wock
thank you CH yeah good morning uh
represent L good to see you uh
question if I was uh
skilled as a
welder and I wanted to create a welding
uh school vocational welding school for
a profit uh and have some of the other
academic pieces to go with it to meet a
two-year associates degree uh in in
mechanical welding etc etc etc and
sculpture and whatever it happens to be
uh would I be unable to apply for I'm
missing that link sure sure so so you
thank thank you for the question um
represent Woodcock um I think you've
conflated a couple of things here though
I mean there are a lot of
for-profit uh occupational educational
um institutions they're not they're not
Institutes of higher education with
degree granting Authority Associates
Bachelors Masters doctorates cags stuff
like that um but they do provide um uh
you know I think you use the term
vocational uh vocational occupational
skills that that have value in the uh in
the marketplace but they're not
necessarily Associates degrees or
bachelor's degrees or or degree granting
Authority and um and you know we've
we've we've obviously had bills in here
that that talk about the number of these
companies whether they're they're um
helping people receive u a u uh you know
ability to to be um you know take a job
as a flomist or as a um as a commercial
driver uh and things like that these are
not businesses that uh that come before
the higher education commission or the
legislature for degree granting um
Authority and uh and you know whether
it's a u uh you know
a you know a business that um that
certifies um people to to you know do do
business as a barber or hair stylist or
you know whatever these these um
occupations that require professional
lure uh in New Hampshire th this doesn't
my understanding is that this does not
get in the way of any of that and I
wouldn't want I don't think any of us
would want it to thank you thank you
chairman further questions from the
committee represent
Ford
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question having served on
several of those kinds of decision
groups that you're talking
about I don't ever
recall that the issue of profitability
of the
Enterprise was a concern in the
discussion it was always and almost
totally focused on how the Integrity of
the Enterprise was Main
mained and I just wonder if you're
somehow in questioning that it has to be
nonprofit asking a question or wondering
whether it can
be a program of
Integrity if it's makes a profit and I'm
not sure
I fully make the connection you seem to
be making yeah no thank you thank you
very much for the for the question
representative Ford and and and you know
I've spent a lot of time in businesses
I've I've founded a business it was not
a nonprofit business it was a for-profit
business and um and
and and there there is a difference in
the between the for-profit world and the
the nonprofit world I think when
representative Tanner was was reading
from the I think the Southern New
Hampshire the the snhu uh website where
it talked about how some of those differ
is um manifest when it comes to and I
don't want I I I don't want to use the
word integrity but I want to use I I
want to do you know doing the best for
its students as opposed to doing the
best for its shareholders and and and
you know I think in in higher education
it's imperative that um that that are
colleges and universities that have
degree granting Authority that come
before the Department of Education for
higher education uh commission approval
and come before uh this esteemed um body
that um that they that they put the
interests of students first and the only
way you you you you can be assured of
that is um is is is by being a nonprofit
um uh organization and um and even then
I suppose that could be a challenge but
um uh but you know the the the the
national trends that have been seen with
with
for-profit uh uh colleges and
universities are like what represented
of Tanner read from the Southern New
Hampshire University uh website that uh
that um that you know the delivery of
services or necessary services for
students can be underresourced resources
for students can be more scarce and um
and you know I think New Hampshire is a
small state and um and and
uh we I don't think I I I think New
Hampshire is very well served by its um
by the um the the nonprofit colleges and
universities that we have and and uh and
especially well served by our public um
colleges and universities uh across the
state and uh and I'd like to see New
Hampshire establish that hard deck for
minimum qualification
to uh to so that we continue to see that
in the
future thank you Mr chair as a followup
to representative Ford's question uh
isn't it true that one of the key things
that the higher education commission
looks at when they're looking at a new
institution is aurity bond to make sure
that the fiscal nature of that
institution is viable so that should
they happen to go out of business that
the students do not suffer as a result
of that and that charity Bond basically
provides an opportunity for students to
be reimbursed if in fact uh the that
institution does cease to exist isn't
that true so so thanks I I I think I
think that is one of the things that the
higher education commission looks at but
I'm certain that is one of the things
that we do have in statute
for um
for these vocational occupational
Training centers uh to make sure that uh
that they have aurity bond in place so
we do have um um some student
Protections in place for vocational
occupational you know Professional
Licensing training organizations but we
don't have we don't have the floor in
place when it comes to uh Institutes of
higher ed that have granting Authority
further questions represent
LE in order
for a business a for-profit business to
stay in business they have to make their
customers happy otherwise their
customers wouldn't use them so I'm
wondering why
you're suggesting that a
for-profit uh degree granting Institute
wouldn't also have to do
that so so thanks I'm not suggesting
that that that that a for-profit
business can operate without customers
it certainly can't and to have customers
clearly they've got to be uh
uh there there's got to be something
about the product that's being delivered
that's important for the customers but
I'm just going to leave it alone on that
because I think in the for-profit world
you see a lot of um things there's
certainly some for-profit companies that
are in the news right now um that are
very important for-profit companies that
that are being criticized maybe for
putting profits above above safety and
um and you know
I again the for-profit world and the
nonprofit world are very different and
um and uh from at least the information
that that I've been able to see and I
think the information that that folks
around the the in on the committee have
been able to see New Hampshire's
colleges and universities are nonprofit
and uh and just looking to to make sure
that we're um we're providing that that
sort of emphasis on on um on on student
focus and students first uh going
forward when you were looking and
signing this bill did you ask the
question of the either University system
or the community college system if
they're accepting cours workk skill work
that a students transferring or wanting
to bring in from a nonprofit or for a
for-profit organization whether they're
getting credit for this from the
University system I did not ask that
question but it's a very good question
yeah thank
you represent
leus moving on to another of the three
parts I'm wondering which accreditation
standards um do
for-profit uh institutions not have that
nonprofit institutions do
have I'm wondering why you put that in
there why why putting nonprofit in there
no why you put
um you made a
comment about standards and
accreditation standards earlier and I'm
wondering
[Music]
um are there accreditation standards
that
for-profit universities don't get that
that uh nonprofit one yeah there there
may be I don't I don't have an easy
answer to that I mean obviously um uh
Nei I think is a is a is a common um uh
uh accreditation that that are that that
colleges and universities have in uh in
the New England area I I I don't know if
there are for-profit organizations that
that have accreditation from Nei or
whether they can or can't get get those
accreditations but I'm sure there are
accreditation authorities for um for for
for-profit institutions thank you thank
you very much not seeing any further
hands thank you very much thank you very
much I do not have any other cards for
for uh 1453 so I'm closing this
hearing and we'll take about 5 minutes
here for a short break before we go on
to the other two bills we have before
lunch
here I need
aink
okay good so we're gon to go ahead here
151 12
yeah okay we're going to go ahead here
with HB 1512 uh limiting education
Freedom account funding to budgeted
amounts and I welcome represent Miler
thank you Mr chair for the record I'm
Mel Miler representative of maram 9
Hopkinson in the town of both uh in
concept Mr uh chair this is a very
simple
Bill uh and uh every two years the state
creates a
budget and in that budget it alloc Ates
how much money should go to each program
and this program basically this bill
basically says that the education
Freedom accounts funding should be held
to whatever the budgeted amount is that
the uh budget committee and the budget
process establishes I have handed out to
you a um information that was received
by the LBA uh from OS and you can see in
the three years of the uh phas what the
budget amount was and what the expended
amount was and you can see that in each
each of the years it has gone over what
the budgeted amount has been and this
bill would basically limit the amount of
EFA grants to uh uh parents to that
budgeted amount that's basically what
the bill is thank you thank you are
there any questions of represent mil
represent Woodcock thank you chairman
chairman Milo thank you uh question
question what
happens uh in actuality um when a a line
item like this goes over three four8
million over the budget account what
happens I have no
idea well thank you okay represent
cordelli did you have a question I S
your hand up uh yeah thank you
um if the uh the budget amount is
reached
um what happens with the uh subsequent
students who might um be uh applying and
who qualify for an account it would see
I don't know the answer to that one
representative cordelli but it would
seem to me that once the uh budget has
been reached that there should be there
could be a warrant that could be issued
uh to the fiscal committee to expend
that if they wanted to do that but right
now that's not
available thank you representative Damon
thank
you are do you have any information
on what
happens or how often other line
item large uh
programs sorry I'm not asking this a
very organized way trying to get
information on whether there's other
programs that overspend the budget and
what happens with that I I don't know
that specifically but I do know that
there's the fiscal committee is
responsible for basically administering
the budget in between the two once the
budget is adopted then they're
responsible for its imp implementation
thank you further
questions represent
leus if a number of school AED children
move into the state of New
Hampshire
and that would then increase the
spending for the state amount of the
adequacy aid what happens
then now I mean now but all that comes
out of the trust fund so why would it be
different for EFA students coming in as
opposed to other student because an
annually there's a a it's it lags a year
behind annually there's a note that the
that the the uh Department of Education
comes up with with what the amount is
and this as we know this year it's like
4150 and it's allocated based upon what
those are and and and if the budget goes
typically in the past when the trust
fund needs more money it comes out of
the general fund and there's a process
to get that right now there's no process
here there's no oversight here at least
to my understanding on how that money
once you reach that budget amount what
what happens to in this case for example
uh in 2023 the 147 versus the 3.3
million I have no idea what the process
is for that 14,000 they ultimately have
been allocated my point is is that once
it's established that it should be it
should follow the same process that any
other program would be with some
oversight as relates to what the
allocations would be for a particular
fiscal year thank you thank you further
questions from the committee representa
Tanner thank you aren't there some funds
like um the special ed or catastrophic
Aid fund that has a budget and then uh
when schools submit their their bills
for that if if um the funding goes over
the budgeted amount it's decreased on a
pro-rated basis to each school so that
like in New Hampshire right now I
believe it's schools only get about 51%
reimbursement for their special ed cost
that's my understanding yes just just to
correct that of the budgeted money for
the catastrophic Aid the the it's been
PR rated to 89% of that state obligation
I'm not talking about the whole special
education gamut of costs I'm talking
about what has been appropriate for that
particular as that Grant area and it's
pro rated down to 89% some years it's
been 100% other years I can remember was
69% you're welcome if I if I might add
to that one one of the I guess one of
the concerns I do have
is a kind of a Cavalier attitude about
this
program uh when we uh dealt with this
issue last Thursday and um we passed the
500% of poverty level I was somewhat uh
shocked uh when it was waved any any
fiscal application of what that would
cost it just waved so let the Senate do
that I don't believe that's the way it
should be do business
here further questions represented
D thank you Mr chair thank you take
another
question I would like to hear your help
me understand
please the fiscal note does not seem to
me to correspond to the language of the
bill in that the bill line 12 into
13 specifically says not exceed
$1,800,000 for fiscal year 2024 and then
talks about subsequent fiscal years and
in the
fiscal note they've somehow concluded
that you could interpret the
bill to double that amount of
dollars well TP I I think makes sense
yeah if I may I'm not a budget expert by
any means but my sense is that that's
what what was budgeted for each each of
the fiscal years that's where that's
where the if you look down at the
towards the bottom of the fiscal note
where it has the 39 the
39651 that's a combination of what was
budget in one year and what was budget
in the second year that's how I that's
those dollars are budgeted for the bium
yeah for the bani not each year for the
bani if you I 30 plus 30 plus million
but that's not what it says it says in
each fiscal year 24 and fiscal year
2025 it doesn't seem like that's what
the bill says but it that if it if you
read that no it says it could be
interpreted
yes and so it's language which is not
really
clear further questions of represent
Miler thank you very
much uh David
Trumble morning
good morning there you go start over
good morning Mr chairman and committee
members um I support this bill from
representative Miler uh for a couple of
reasons and this a lot of this will be
similar to what we talked about under
the other bill this morning about the
annual
eligibility first the EFA program is a
discretionary program and I made this
point earlier but I do want to stress it
again there's no constitutional mandate
that efas exist like there is a
constitutional mandate that we must fund
our Public Schools that's directly from
our Constitution and from The Claremont
case so secondly I would say that means
that this program should be treated like
every other discretionary program in the
state budget if you have a
constitutional mandate to spend on
something then maybe you have a blank
check because you have to spend on it
you have no choice we don't have to
spend on efas therefore it should be
treated like other discretionary
programs for instance um invest New
Hampshire in an affordable housing
program they will finance a fixed number
of units they're spending tens of
millions of dollars we know we need way
more than they're funding for that
program but they've picked an amount
that they're going to spend the
university system of New Hampshire gets
a certain amount they got a certain
amount to fix Spalding Hall but the
universities are constantly saying they
need more money but we don't give it to
them we give them a certain amount they
have to stay within that budget the
division of Developmental Services gets
a certain amount of money and the state
is been party to numerous lawsuits about
waiting lists but they get a certain
amount of money that they can spend
School building Aid has I was listening
to a hearing last week on that they have
a competitive system for applications
they don't Grant and pay immediately
everyone you they have to go through a
process so I think the EFA should be
treated like every other discretionary
program and get a certain amount of
money the next thing I want to talk
about is the net cost of public schools
this question came up from
representative leus earlier this morning
but I'd like to just walk through it
again there have been claims that the
EFA program saves schools money saves
Town's money saves Public Schools money
but it doesn't really save money it's a
theoretical savings that sure it costs
an average of 20,000 to educate each
student but if you take two students out
of every public school and they go over
to a private school through the EFA
program that school doesn't save money
and again I'll just walk through some of
the statistics from earlier in the con
decision teachers are 66% of the budget
losing two students in a middle school
in your big town is not going to lead to
any teachers being fired the other
professionals guidance Library
custodians principles 14% you're not
going to fire a custodian if two
children leave your public school and
join an EFA the facilities are 15% you
still have to fix the roof you still
have to heat and put the lights on and
the only difference is the instructional
material and Technology that's 4% or 4
$400 so the EFA program does not in the
real world save money and if people want
to make that claim I would just say
present some data to the public you now
have several years of this program let
the institutions who do nonprofit
research whether it's the center for
Budget uh policy Mr Klein's group or
it's reaching higher New Hampshire the
New Hampshire school funding project
give them some data that you've track 10
schools the impact of vfas on them and
show whether or not there is an actual
savings or better yet bring in six
superintendant they it's budget season
they have their data ask them the simple
question your school we know lost two
students through efas what was the
impact on your budget and I bet you
they'll tell you none if anything
negative because they lose some of that
adequacy money so I think there needs to
be an understanding that this program
and the public school funding programs
interact with each other at a
fundamental Financial level if you take
more money and put it into this program
it's not available for the public
schools and the conv Val decisions
coming down the highway you're going to
need to come up with $500 million more
money this certainly means that we
should not be spending on it with
unlimited funds on a program giving it a
blank check uh unless you can and last
week the question was how would it be
implemented I thought representative
myor was correct send it back to the
finance committee and have another
debate do we want to spend more money or
you could do a declining benefit system
public Housing Works that way as your
income Rises and you get closer to the
eligibility cut off point your benefit
drops so maybe if you say we only have1
million what we'll do is adopt the
declining benefit model so that if
you're at the poverty level you get the
$5,000 as you go further up and income
towards that 500% Mark you get a
declining benefit that would be one way
to allow every child who's in the
program to stay in the program and
families would know where they stand
that as they earn more money they have
to pay a little bit more themselves and
get a little less from the state there's
certainly ways it could be done but the
basic point I wanted to make was if it's
constitutionally required you have to
pay it if it's not constitutionally
required there's no reason to put a
blank check it should be treated like
every other discretionary program like
Housing Programs developmental services
and the university system so thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions for Mr
Trumble not seeing any thank you very
much thank you Mr chairman and I have no
other pin cards on this bill so we are
closed
1512 and uh get ready to go into HB
1108 1108 uh relative to establishing a
committee to study the role of colleges
and universities in contributing to the
student loan
crisis
yeah
right good morning again Mr chair and
members of the committee
beler for the record representative
beler Carol District 4 out of
Wakefield so this bill establishes seeks
to establish a committee
to look at the student loan crisis and I
don't think any argument can be made
against the fact that we do in fact have
a student loan crisis in this
country this problem is substantially
responsible for the number of Young
Americans who are having difficulty
purchasing homes starting families and
moving on in their
careers as such this problem not only
affects the borrowers this problem
affects American American culture
generally we must take up this issue
with the seriousness that it
deserves we must look for Solutions and
we must look to see what can be done to
curtail the issue going
forward there are very many arguments
from very many different people
identifying possible causal factors and
attributing responsibility for the
crisis I can't address all those right
now but what I can say
unequivocally is one party can be ruled
out entirely as having any
responsibility for this situation and
that is the
taxpayer it's not the taxpayer's fault
that students signed on and borrowed
large sums of money sometimes hundreds
of thousands of dollars it's not it's
not the taxpayer's fault that government
took over and began backing student
loans which appears to have uh
immediately preceded the skyrocketing of
costs and expansion of non-teaching
positions it's not the taxpayer's fault
that colleges and universities lobbied
the government to back student
loans and proceeded to abgate their
responsibilities to the students by
increasing costs dramatically and hiring
more and more non-teaching
personnel as such I don't think it makes
a lot of sense that we look for foremost
to the taxpayer to solve this problem
through either direct taxation or
inflation which robs their Savings of
its value
indirectly I think we should instead be
looking at the government and at the
colleges and universities themselves to
determine what if any responsibility
they hold for this
crisis of course I believe there is more
than reasonable
articulable uh suspicion to carry out an
investigation into this matter and to
make
recommendations on any findings that can
be come up with if we're serious about
tackling the student loan crisis we need
to investigate its Origins and identify
the responsible
parties so that we can solve the problem
without implicating parties that had no
role in creating the problem in the
first place thank you I will take
questions thank you very much representa
cordelli uh thank you uh I'm just
unclear as to how you expect um five
house members and one Senator to come up
with this information I just did a quick
search last night on the internet um
there are plenty plenty of studies out
there student loan debt crisis from the
Education data initiative causes and
solutions to the student debt crisis
from the Annie Casey Foundation um
America's student loan crisis from the
credit abuse resistance educ ucation um
student debt analysis higher ed funding
data from Pew charitable trust and I
could go on I've got a whole page long
list here with just a few minutes search
on the internet plenty of people are
looking at this and identifying the
problems so what more can a group of
five representatives and one Senators
bring to this issue thank you that's a
very good question there is a lot of
data out there there's a lot of private
parties looking at this putting forward
good reports but what they can't do
is they can't issue legislative findings
or potential legislation to try to
address the problem and I think that's
where it falls to us as a body to be
able to look at this and see not just
not just say well this part party
appears to have from responsibility but
is there legislation we can move forward
to address the problem or at the very
least to Cil it going
forward further
questions i' represent belard not see
any questions thank you very much thank
you
are there any other pin cards on this
bill not seeing any so we will close the
hearing for
1108 this takes us through the bills be
heard this morning we will be meeting
again at 1:00 today uh for the purpose
of looking at uh subcommittee work on
1288 which is referencing
uh due process rights for student
organizations faculty members facing
disciplinary actions by state
institutions higher educ and 1305 which
is the freedom of speech and association
bill which we have dealt with so that
will be a work session starting at
1:00 so with
that we are done the hearing process for
today so we'll close this down and we'll
break for an early lunch um there will
be a caucus in this room
uh Jen so can we let the people upstairs
know that we will be caucusing thank
you
e
well good afternoon everybody um this is
a subcommittee work session for two
bills we have today hb1
1288 followed by HB
1305 we are going to take up first hb1
1288 that is an early bill which we have
to have acted we have to act on that
bill and out of here by the 15th so
we'll be executing this bill on the
14th HB 1288 is relative to establishing
certain due process rights for students
student organizations and faculty
members facing disciplinary actions by
state institutions of Higher
Learning we've had a hearing on this
previously and today we're having a work
session to address whether there be uh
amendments to this or to get get further
answers on some of the questions so uh
we have the prime sponsor of the bill
here represent Lynn and how how many
people are here for this or
both okay so we have okay so there's
there's going to be a lot of activity
here on on both of these
bills uh what the university system just
must must have had a caucus in the
hallway
way okay so this this meeting is
streamed and so um I'd like to uh repres
and Lynn could you give us a brief
overview of the bill and then
to we can go into questions and then
some of the discussion which we have for
you absolutely thank you Mr chair um
members of the committee um as I uh
indicated during my testimony basically
this is this bill is designed to uh
ensure that um students student
organizations and faculty members uh
that are facing
disciplinary action uh have their due
process rights uh protected um and and I
think I I kind of you know just went
went into a fair fair amount of detail
when I first testified um there were
questions raised and I know I I worked
with representative beler um about
issues that were raised and I know one
of the one of the uh significant issues
that was were was raised by um members
of the of the community college system
and I think the university system was
that the way the bill had originally
been drafted it had I had also had it
apply to something less than a
suspension um for example a rep I think
it said reprimand or uh even something
less than that and I think there was a
concern expressed about that maybe goes
too far they have you know there I think
there was uh representative luno you may
have raised the issue of you know
someone if a student is uh making too
much noise in the dormatory and and they
you know they they basically tell him to
cut it out or give them some some the
student some uh some very low level of
uh of discipline does that St do we have
to invoke all of the due process
rights um and I I you know I I still
have some concern about that but
I you know I'm I very much believe in
compromising and I and uh this proposed
amendment takes out the it has to be at
least a suspension um and so I you know
I I mean I certainly can can live with
that I understand the concerns that are
raised about not turning you know a mole
hill into a mountain so to speak uh
where where there's very low levels of
discipline so I can you know I can kind
of live with that um uh and so that
that's you know that's one of the big
things that uh that is is proposed as a
change in the amendment
um and I'm happy to to discuss I'm happy
to discuss the other changes that are it
sounds like instead of a 30-foot tsun
tsunami we're going to have a one foot
right right okay um uh do we have the we
we do have an amendment put forth here
represent beler you're also a sponsor
along with representa ly does everybody
in the audience have copies of this
amendment for
okay y yes
0332 okay are there
represent Bel you can come up to the
table as well seeing that you are also a
a sponsor on
this are there any questions from the
committee regarding the amendment is
there anything represent beler that you
feel that needs to be explained about
the amendment that has not been said to
date sure if if you I will sure um so as
uh as repent indicated we remove the
reprimand Port uh just because of the
issues that that could potentially
create um we added an area surrounding
the idea of criminal allegations or
allegations that could be of a criminal
nature and we did that recognizing that
our court system is in the business of
Justice that's their primary goal and
role whereas in universities it's more
of a secondary function so at the uh at
the we added a definition but also at
the end we added a clause that if there
is a criminal proceeding brought against
a student then the uh University or
college uh must hold off on their
disciplinary proceedings until the
professional Justice is done but they
can still take um disciplinary measures
on a temporary basis until that point in
time under the sort of presumption that
there was probable cause to do
so there are questions on what was just
stated who brings forth the the um the
uh need for a criminal proceeding who
makes that allegation
well well I mean if that would be um
that would that would be prosecutorial
authorities you know the county attorney
or the Attorney General it would have to
be a prosecutorial Authority that would
make the decision to prosecute you know
the one other thing that um along the
same line that I think is important to
point out you'll notice that in the in
the amendment in paragraph Roman numeral
4 um there's a provision that was added
um and this was based on my discussions
with with between representative vure
myself that says that if there's been an
adjudication by the by the student
disciplinary procedures if there's been
a
determination that is not
admissible in the criminal uh uh
proceeding um and the and the reason for
that
is under the Rules of Evidence I wish I
I I forgot to bring them with me but
under the rules of evidence that apply
in court there are certain circumstances
in which a determination by an
administrative tribunal or some kind of
fact-f finding
tribunal can in some cases be admitted I
think if I recall correct I wish I had
the rule in front of me but I think I
think basically it can only be admitted
against the government or so against the
state in other words there might be
circumstances in which let's say that
where's a discipline lary proceeding in
the uh you know in the the school
disciplinary proceeding and the student
was
found um not to have violated the um the
the code or or uh yeah not not to have
violated the student code just as an
example um there might be circumstances
in which that
finding would be admissible against the
state in the criminal proceeding there
might be I mean I suppose there could
also be circumstances in which in which
even a even a finding like a of that a
victim had lied or something like that
arguably could be admissible in a Crim
in a criminal proceeding this is
designed to say no that's that that will
not happen the criminal proceeding will
the evidence the whatever the evidence
might be you know that certainly can be
can be admitted but the finding of the
tribunal is not not is not to be
admitted in the criminal proceeding um
and that seemed to make that that seemed
to me to make sense um and I think it
representative belshire agreed
so with this understanding perhaps it'
be a a a good time if we don't have
questions right now further we will have
questions but that we should have some
of those that are here to speak
regarding this to come forward and
present their perspective
uh and where we are on this um who'd
like to be up
first
commissioner glad to love to have the
agriculture Department here well I am
not here as Commissioner of
Agriculture and for the record I am Sean
Jasper not appearing as commissioner of
the Department of Agriculture markets
and food but H appearing as chapter
advisor to the Alpha gamar fraternity
which is the agricultural fraternity at
UNH uh to which I have been advisor for
the past 36
years um in my role as commissioner to
just be transparent I also serve uh as a
university system member of the the
Board of Trustees and I have had many of
these conversations of things that I'm
going to share with you um with others
over the years and really while there
has been some progress
made the thing about that is so much of
it is dependent on who is in the
office so things can EB and flow and I
do think that there should be
Protections in in legislation to
protect the parties here and I'm going
to read you uh one paragraph from an
email that I sent in uh on May 14th 2022
which I think summarizes some of my
concerns and this was to um the
assistant or Greek advisor or now called
fraternity and sorority life advisor and
I said yesterday my intent was to try to
ensure that AGR was provided with due
process which includes my right to
advise the president throughout the
process I also made a statement about my
lack lack of trust in the system I have
been chapter advised for 34 years and
during that time I have seen processes
procedures and standards used that would
never be allowed in our legal system to
me it is not only wrong but Al also very
sad in a university setting everything
that is taught by the university should
be done according to the higher
standards I hope that you would agree
students on both sides of the process
should be learning about how an ethical
judicial process works again I hope you
agree sadly in the the several judicial
processes that I have been part of over
the years I've never come away with the
feeling that either of those objectives
have been met even when I offered to
work with the university on those issues
after our case was adjudicated I was
ultimately
ignored and so that's why this bill
caught my eye it had not spoken to the
sponsors before uh before I saw the
hearing of this um this bill and so
things that have happened happened in
the process have been such as and this
was a number of years ago that the
chapter was
suspended our president was planning on
meeting with the at that time was the
Greek advisor went into that meeting and
there was the dean of students who
handed him a letter of suspension there
had been no contact no no opportunity to
respond to what had gone on and in fact
fact as we got into the process and we
had to spend some $88,000 to defend the
fraternity which ultimately it was not
the fraternity that was really found
responsible but two
individual um individuals within the
fraternity
um it found out that couple of th I
think there were three who wanted to get
out of the housing situation at the
fraternity went to to the Greek adviser
to see how they could get out and what
he was told is I can only help you if
you give me dirt on
AGR and then he became the complaint and
called the police ultimately there was
nothing that the police found but it was
a really ugly
process I put unbelievable number of
hours into that so that was one case
that was a number of years ago the more
recent one again was just if you look at
the the rules and IFC technically into
fraternity council is technically an
independent governing body in reality it
it really
isn't um we received a letter and this
was simp a simple matter which didn't go
any any place other than a loss of
social privileges for a week and was
settled informally but it was you look
at this process and the chapter advisor
is not allowed to participate you know
you're putting these students into this
situation where they're defending
organization and they've probably never
gone through this again they're not only
just facing a peer but um um the Greek
advisor as well and it seems proper as
this bill points out to allow that that
advisor to participate in the process
um I'll give you another example which
isn't so much perhaps on
point but the really shows what I've had
to go through
so during the the pandemic the
fraternity received notice from the
University that HHS from the state
wanted a list of the names of all of the
men living in the chapter house well
that seemed very strange to me so I went
back and forth and I've got the email
chain here I won't bore you with with
that but ultimately I just kept getting
well the state wants it the state wants
it they don't want their medical
conditions they just want to know who's
living there I said well to myself well
that's very strange the state doesn't go
around asking who's living where now I
had known for years the university had
been trying to get lists of who was
living in in the house that's up to the
individuals we don't share their living
situations with them ultimately after
being told yes this is what the state
wants I have that in writing I contacted
HHS I contacted the person who had been
dealing with the university and was told
no we have not requested that
information we don't have a database to
keep that information in all we've said
is if there is an an outbreak of covid
among a significant number of people in
a building we want to know who's living
there which is is reasonable so hence I
go back to even as a as a
trustee there's a lack of trust and
there needs to be um a better system but
particularly on the judicial side there
should be that due process that should
um exist and no matter how I have tried
to deal with it over the
years I have made little progress
perhaps some with the current
Administration and again I mean I I like
the people who are all behind me from
the University I'm not blaming any of
them but it seems to be a system that
sometimes controls itself and not the
individuals controlling the system and
depending on who are in those particular
roles things can change very
dramatically and so that's why I do
think this is very important I'd be glad
to answer any questions thank you um the
egg fraternity that's a separate
Corporation right that is correct and
are they living on campus or off campus
all the fraternities are located off
campus and so therefore the uh
controlled in terms of our housing
Arrangement who's who has the police
Authority that is Durham Police and not
the as police so if a complaint is made
to Paul Dean chief of police down to u
university system New
Hampshire
UNH who who responds is it the Durham
Police Department the responds and how's
that work yes it is it is the Durham
Police Department so he would no doubt
notify if there was a complaint that
came through campus police he would pass
that on to the you um to the Town police
and we have a very good relationship uh
with both um both departments and don't
have any any issues and they haven't had
any issues with us this is more this
internal thing where in in some cases
frankly there are people within the
system looking for things for instance
one of the things that I've been arguing
about for years is the university con
considers a fraternity event anything
this is a short version the whole
language is here anything where if you
looked at a number of people and and
realized they were Greek you could say
hey that's a fraternity event no matter
if it was 5 10 or or whatever and I've
been trying to argue to say you know in
our case we have a chapter house that
holds 24 members if we have 48 members
there that's you know
um the residents and a guest each um the
university only allows registration on
Thursday
um two nights you can register Thursday
Friday or Saturday but it can't be a
Friday and Saturday together um but if
they are aware of any number of people
together in the fraternity house they
haven't bothered as if it's just the
guys hanging out but if they have any
guests over then that's an unregistered
social event and we subject to um
disciplinary action and I've said we
have the right to do that we're well
under what is considered um a need for a
um occupancy permit from the fire
department and our Corporation has told
the guys look as long as you stay under
50 we're fine with that we expect that
you're going to have friends over and
you may all have friends over but that's
not supported by the university rules
and then people will post pictures on on
social media people have trolled for
that we actually had a a
situation um last last year where yep
they had a a party just some of the guys
and their
girlfriends at the end of the semester
but it was after a period when socials
were allowed I didn't consider that to
be a social there were probably less
than 20 people participating and yet
we're somebody's trolling somebody's
reporting and then without knowing who
that person is is and this is these
people don't have to come as Witnesses
they don't have to tell us how they got
the pictures or whatever you just make a
complaint and then um the disciplinary
action starts and we never find out you
know what's going on in terms where due
process come in well there is no due
process in in that part of it um and
that's where I feel that you know as as
the amendment to the bill perhaps the
bill itself talks about you know
cross-examining Witnesses and talking to
to people I think we have the right to
know in due process who is making the
allegation and talking to them about
that I feel I've always felt very
strongly about that you can't should not
just be going out there making
allegations and often because there's no
other complaint it's really the
university itself making the complaint
but we have no no ability to
cross-examine or talk to the to the
originator of the complaint thank you
are there any questions from the yes
represent
luno sure thank you very much Mr chair
thank you very much commissioner for
joining us as your in Your Capacity as
fraternity advisor um so I I've got a
little bit of experience um uh being in
Greek life uh in another institution and
um and as I recall um when um when there
was um maybe dis plenary action being
cons considered before things went to uh
the Dean's office um
uh the inner fraternity Council would
get involved and the IFC I believe was a
was a an organization on campus with
members from each of the the the
fraternity fraternities on campus that
would um um you know review complaints
and I was wondering does does that type
of due process exist at UNH it does on
on the
minor um offenses but as I've said it's
really intertwined because it's really
uh that process and what goes on really
is controlled to a large degree by the
Greek the fraternity and sority life
advisor I mean it is very hard to to
totally separate the two of them which I
think they should be but the way it
practically works it doesn't um the
letter that we received again I have it
here um about the minor infraction which
we we dealt with through a um an
informal process which worked well
frankly I didn't want to go that route
because I was I felt so strongly that
having 12 to 20 people in your house is
just not how do how do you how do they
get to tell us we can't use our our
facilities the guys decided that it
wasn't worth it um but that letter came
and said you are in violation of
now would you like a
hearing you know they did Apologize
later saying yeah they they needed to
update their form letters um but again
you know it's not totally independent
because you go to the informal hearing
and the one of the staff members from
fraternity sorority life is there
advising the um person who's in charge
of the charge of the judicial process
for IFC so I don't really see them as as
independent
thank you further questions from the
committee thank you very much thank
you um like to ask that we now have I
see we have Tom Cronin
here anybody else from un or the
university system that you like to have
come up at the same time we have a few
of us if I could start and then maybe
pass it off because I think there's
people who will speak to different
pieces all right so I think so thank you
uh members of the committee Tom pronin
with the University system uh so first
just want to say thank you to
representative Glenn representative
beler for working through the amendment
certainly the the adjustment in the
disciplinary proceeding section uh we
appreciate being heard on that during uh
the hearing that said I think there are
still challenges inside of this
amendment and ultimately it doesn't
significantly change the underlying text
of 1288 um and so what I I hope we could
do is maybe have a couple appropriate
folks walk through uh both on the HR and
our collective bargaining side and then
also our student Affair side uh just was
some of the concerns that they had
shared with us as we were working
through this um and then hopefully to
kind of take questions from there just
quickly on the amendment I think and I
don't know if this was an an error or
purposeful uh we had a conversation
during the hearing uh that we were
concerned about the the definition of
faculty member uh and again I'm not sure
if it was meant but the amendment
strikes aary status um which essentially
would give then full protection to a
faculty member on their first day full
or part-time we also discussed obviously
there's a range of different faculty
types at the University in full and
part-time doesn't entirely cover that um
again folks will speak a little bit more
to this and we are just reading the new
section four uh but that does seem to
raise a number of concerns that sort of
handcuff us a bit in the event that
actual criminal charges are filed
against uh either a student or a faculty
member um in terms of how we can proceed
there you know I think with the
exception of the commissioner's points
he made a second ago that I think our
our colleagues from Student Life can
discuss I think our main point at the
hearing a few weeks ago was simply there
is not there are not complaints at the
University system or the community
college system that are warranting 1288
and that we have between our student
rules rights and responsibilities our
collective bargaining agreements and
even for folks who would not be covered
by this due process rules for all of our
employees that cover uh everything we're
trying to accomplish here so I'm hopeful
that with my colleagues speaking through
a couple of their concerns we can
continue to see that we have a a strong
body of policy behind this um that sort
of makes 1288
unnecessary so with that if I can I
think I'd like to ask Tracy and John
Wallen to speak first from the HR and
collective bargaining site thank you
Tom
thank you for the opportunity to speak
with you this morning I'm Tracy
Birmingham I'm the associate General
counsil with the university system of
New Hampshire
um uh good afternoon I'm John Wall and
I'm the assistant proost at the
University of near Hampshire I
administer the can you speak a little
louder oh I'm sorry is that better
that's better all right excellent sorry
uh good afternoon I'm John Wallen I'm
the assistant provos at the University
of New Hampshire I serve as the chief
negotiator for the University on the
collective bargaining agreements with
our faculty and I'm the administrator of
the uh agreements uh so uh I manage the
among other things grievance process
that
um yes mirrors a lot of the language in
1288 so I wanted to approach this first
I mic down a little bit more yeah right
um I work with the university
extensively on our employment
relationships and one of the things that
I think it's important for us to
understand this proposed bill
would impact certain classes of
employees which includes student
employees and faculty but not all of our
employees um one of the things that Tom
was alluding to we already have very
extensive due process protections the
university system embodies in policy
something that we feel is really
important which from an employment
perspective always a first objective is
to make sure that our employees are
heard and that we have the opportunity
to engage with our with our employees
one of the things that this bill puts
forward is really an adversarial system
which would replace our current system
which is a really robust due process
protection that also allows us as an
employer to work with our
employees which for those of you who
work in an employment environment is
really important to make sure that we
have a collegial environment that allows
for our employees to work with each
other in a way that's effective the bill
would substitute for that something that
looks much more like an adversarial
system and some of the process that we
see here would really undermine what we
try to
do try speak a little more loudly uh in
addition to everything that try had said
the
language even um in the uh amended
language that we shared with us today uh
regarding uh one disciplinary proceeding
and the removal of uh the word uh
reprimanded uh doesn't actually address
um in his totality the concerns that we
have about the first level of
uh discipline uh occurring in a
typically informal fashion and in fact
most often uh cases that may and in
suspension or termination of A Faculty
member's uh Position will start with a
far more innocuous uh discussions an
example may be uh that a student reports
a faculty member canceling a class uh
something that would be very normal as a
routine part of A Faculty member's day
uh but their chair may want to speak to
them about that or their Dean may want
to speak to them about that and as part
of that discussion May determine or may
discover that in fact it was not a
single class that was canceled there was
a pattern of these classes being
canceled and in fact the faculty member
has not been responsive to students and
that may lead to something that was not
known or intended at the time of the
initial discussion and I think that the
way that this language in n288 is
drafted um it it creates an impediment
to having those earlier conversations in
a more collegial way in a time frame
that is uh more quick and remediating
the concerns of the vast majority of
complaints that come in in a more time
sensitive and and appropriate fashion
uh the other point uh to something that
Tom had raised earlier with respect to
three faculty member meaning a full or
part-time member of The Faculty of a
public institution of higher education
uh without taking too much of the
committee's time I did just want to
address that faculty uh come in all
shapes and sizes not just full or
part-time but in fact uh we have a
number of Faculty who are not employees
of the University of New Hampshire but
are considered members of The Faculty uh
those would be individuals who are
considered either affiliate faculty
members or visiting faculty members who
may be employed by another institution
uh during their time at the University
they are still afforded the opportunity
uh and the due process that is outlined
in our policies I'm raising that simply
to point out that it would not uh be
captured uh in the language under
three I apologize One More point to
build off of that um John alluded to the
timeliness issue as an employer as all
of you probably know we have obligations
to follow up if we have employees who
raise concerns to timely follow up on
that our current due process protection
contemplate that so to John's point
about we work with folks early and
collegially to address issues but if we
have employees who are raising concerns
to us we have legal obligations to
follow up on that timely promptly and
our existing process I think does that
very effectively some of the things we
see in the new bill with timelines
requirements for disclosures a really
adversarial process I think would
probably be impediments to doing that
timeline
are there anything further no thank you
any questions yes representative Miler
uh thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here so the question that I would
have is that uh what is your what do you
believe that the impact I've got two
questions actually what would be the
impact of
1288 as proposed to your policies and
your CBA that you have that that you're
working off of right now that's question
one please you want to start yeah I'd be
happy to um so the way that our
collected bargaining Agreements are
drafted in the way that um the Canon of
labor law works is a traditionally
around a progressive disciplinary
process I'm sorry I'm Miss speaking
loudly enough thank you around a
progressive disciplinary process uh
which uh ensures that before any um
action uh adverse to an employees
employment status is taken they are
afforded the opportunity to have a
discussion and to provide uh that
information as I said earlier that is
most often in most instances uh done
verbally uh and is done either
informally or fairly quickly um meaning
quickly from when we are aware of the
issue to when we try and have that
conversation so that we're working with
and supporting our employee as quickly
as possible so that they are aware of
the concern they can provide what they
uh believe to be the facts or their
explanation for the behavior if in fact
it occurred
uh and we can work with them uh
supporting them in uh contining to move
forward in in a productive employment
relationship so if I may yes so if if
I'm hearing what you're
saying that the proposed
1288 could
interfere with that early
step of the in your definition of
collegial
environment that it would interfere with
that early step of trying to seek some
sense of
resolution to the issue prior to an
official movement into a uh a
progressive discipline kind of an
approach that this would uh call for is
that correct yes representative that's
exactly correct thank you so what's HR
do then when you have an issue going on
is there not an informal step that's
taken prior to either a reprimand
suspension or
in in in K through2 we call it
revification of of of your teaching
ticket but you it would be exp expulsion
isn't there anything informal that goes
on prior to those possible three steps
which were in the bill has introduced
two steps which are in the
amendment go ahead yeah and I think
you've put your finger right on the
issue our process right now has a lot of
steps before we get to something that
would be as significant as that but the
proposed bill is talking about needing
to take immediately into an adversarial
situation anytime if it could result in
that so to John's point when we start
our process which is always
intentionally at the outset we want to
have discussions with folks that could
result
in serious discipline depending on what
happened so the bill as proposed to your
point would put us in a position to say
all of those early stage processes would
be put into doubt to say could we do
that consistent with the law if this
went forward to say we would be then in
Jeopardy to say well did we do the
process that requires Witnesses written
statements um it's just inconsistent
with how the employment relationship
works so are those informal stages
you're talking about is that part of the
due
process that we now are looking at in
terms of this legislation which is
taking steps beyond the policy that's
designed within
UNH but part of the problem is it's
eliminating in some respects it would
eliminate all of the options we have
under existing policy to try to address
things less in the outside of the
adversarial process the bill is
proposing an adversarial process really
anytime something could lead lead to
significant discipline our current
process by policy and John can speak to
in our cbas talk about doing oral verbal
conversations we do oral warnings we do
a first written warning oftentimes those
are you as casual as conversations in an
office so that you can give people
immediate feedback that could ultimately
lead to discipline but that doesn't mean
from our perspective that the situation
is best addressed by making it
adversarial from the
outset and the bill as proposed seems to
contemplate
that the process you're talking about
here your collective bargaining
agreements with those that are employed
what about the students that would not
come underneath the CVA that now where's
their informal process yeah and you've
raised another very good point because
and our colleagues will speak to them
the student EXP experience as students I
can speak to it as students as employees
one of the educational one of the
purposes of um we employ
students as part of their educational
Mission or our educational Mission along
with it helps get things done but
students are employees and under our
existing policies they're entitled to
some of the same due process that we
apply to our other employees one of the
other challenges when I was looking at
this bill was to say well we're creating
two classes of employees we've got
student employees who will be subject to
the bill we've got faculty who are
employees who would be subject to the
bill and then we have a whole host of
other employees who would fall under our
existing policies from my experience
particularly for student employees that
informal non-adversarial process is
really important because often times
these are young workers and when I say
young I mean new to employment and it's
really important to them to have that
educational opportunity that comes with
giving a new employee feedback and this
process that's contemplated with the
bill will make it an adversarial process
that really I think is going to
undermine that important aspect of
student
employment further questions from the
committee represent
cordelli thank you thank you for being
here and explaining uh the
uh processes you have in CBA um but if
there is the informal conversations and
discussions that that you talked about
um at some point there might well be uh
further discipline required and would
would wouldn't you have in place
something that's um Ain to what is laid
out on page two of the bill yeah so
specific to the collective bargaining
agreements that we have currently we
have a process that was negotiated with
obviously uh the representatives for
those um agreements they are similar to
but different um in terms of the timing
that occurs uh in terms of the way that
notification is uh is provided and
processed in terms of uh the
identification of which Advocates uh are
permissive to be able to be brought to
that as well as uh the scope uh and the
potential outcomes um that could occur
the standard is also different uh for
moving forward with a uh termination
case against for example a 10e faculty
member we have a just cause standard
that we have to uh that we have to meet
which is different than the
preponderance standard that's included
here um we also have um additional steps
in our process uh that require uh the
engagement of the president of the
institution uh the engagement of our
faculty Senate uh for peer review and
disciplinary uh recommendations uh as
well as the opportunity for uh obviously
the individual to afford themselves uh
to a representative from the UN from
their Union uh to be in attendance at
all uh meetings that they have with the
administration represent M thank you
again thank you uh for responding to my
question um how many unions do you have
uh at the University at the University
of New Hampshire currently we have four
threee faculty and one is uh as you uh
noted earlier with uh Chief Dean and the
police department
just on a followup I'm assuming that
your student employees are not unionized
correct that is correct so the the issue
of dealing with issues where does past
practice come in as a as it relates to
solving similar issues uh with your
particularly with your student with your
student group sure Tracy yeah and the
student your your spot on is closer
please yeah the practice with respect to
our student employees is the import
important aspect that you're you're
highlighting it's our practice when we
have student employees to work with them
in that process that I discussed to say
you discuss issues in their employment
verbally first followed by you know
process that becomes more
formal I I still don't have my mind
fixed to what's going on here the bill
itself says relative to establishing
certain due process rights for students
student organizations we're not talking
student employees we may be but we're
talking about students that are there to
learn the academics and to have a little
bit of fun on campus and um and
organizations like we heard about the
fraternity earlier so they're not
employees what's the first step for them
is there an informal process of
notifying them that who has made the the
concern who you know submitted that and
how are we going to work with you to try
and correct this you want yeah and I
think as we're talking about students in
the student as students being subject to
student discipline I think we have some
colleagues who will speak to that and I
apologize if I've kind of created um
confusion about the students as
employees versus students as students
there is an entirely different process
for them um which Tom alluded to our
student rules rights responsibilities
document creates extensive due process
protections for students as they are
engaged with our um student conduct
process versus the student employment
which is frankly a much less significant
thank you so maybe it's best that we
move to the those that can come up and
speak
to the what 1400
students that you're dealing
with 14,000 I mean
yeah big difference
yeah
good afternoon my name is Mike Blackman
I'm the Dina students at the University
of New Hampshire been there for about
three years now and I'm noting that to
state that I am a different Dina
students than the DEA students referen
by commissioner Jasper earlier in the
day afternoon thank you for having me my
name is Alexis Pinero Benson I'm the
director of community standards I
oversee and administer the University's
disciplinary
system so I'll try not to repeat much of
what my colleague shared earlier today
but I'll note that the purpose behind
the bill is good that we believe that
students and student organizations
should be afforded due process
protections no matter what the
allegation is and as has been referenced
a couple times we have extensive conduct
procedures that are described in our
student rights rules and
responsibilities handbook that say for
any sanction what a student can expect
in terms of of those due process
protections we know that students
education is a thing of value to them
and that doing anything that impacts
that education is depriving them of that
uh property and that value and we take
that responsibility seriously and as has
been stated the due process protections
afforded to students are proportional to
the potential sanction and so I want to
acknowledge that the change the
amendment raising the bar removing the
word reprimand and raising the bar by
which this applies to students uh to
suspension or potential expulsion is
good and we believe that when a student
is facing potential loss for their
education either temporarily or
permanently that there should be
extensive due process protections
afforded to them that will be more
extensive than when a student is
potentially getting a warning for
holding a beer while they're
underage I will say that um a few
remaining amendments would still be
helpful if it all to be considered
the first being that uh defining student
organizations to only apply when student
organizations have actually been
recognized versus seeking organization
uh seeking recognition status for our
purposes a group of students that is
seeking recognition is not formally
recognized and does not have the
protections afforded to a recognized
student organization they are just a
group of students at that point in
addition we would recommend that a
similar threat hold bar be applied to
student organizations as it was to
students in the amendment raising the
bar by which the disciplinary proceeding
would be defined to include suspension
and Beyond to be the same for student
organizations uh student organizations
facing loss of recognition or suspension
or dismissal from the school we believe
that those should have more significant
due process protections and similarly
when we're issuing a student
organization a warning because they've
been a little bit too loud um we
certainly think they should have due
process protections afforded to them but
those should be different from when a
student organization is potentially
facing the loss of
recognition I also want to address um
and then I'll pause the amendment on the
second page certainly understanding the
importance of um not having evidence
from a disciplinary proceeding be
admissible in a court of law I will say
that the second sentence and beyond that
requires that we wait until the criminal
proceeding be complete before we proceed
with a disciplinary proceeding on our
end would be incredibly challenging for
us um we have an obligation to respond
quickly and swiftly when we learn of a
potential violation I understand the
motivation behind it but we know that
Court proceedings can sometimes take
months or years to complete and under
many laws we have an obligation to
respond as Tracy referenced um within a
certain time frame or even if a certain
time frame hasn't be specified that we
still act quickly to protect our
community and if we're not able to do
that and have to wait for potentially
months or years for a criminal
proceeding to be over that would really
limit our ability to do that uh I
understand that there was a clause put
in to say that we can take temporary
actions pending the completion of a
criminal proceeding however any interim
actions that we Implement are meant to
address highly significant Behavior we
have a very high threshold for when we
do that because the nature of an interim
action means that the student is not
getting their due process protections
under the code of conduct we're acting
quickly so it would not be ideal to be
implementing many temporary or interim
measures waiting for a criminal
proceeding to complete we want to be
able to give students their full process
as quickly and resolve these things for
students as quickly as we can
thank you Mike um is Alex Alexis yeah is
do you have anything anything else to
add right now Mya students is such a
great
job this is the new Dean too the new
Dean yes abely so questions from the
committee yes represent Miler yes thank
you and thank you for being here could
you review for us the various
levels from just a conversation
what are the what are the levels of due
process and actions that you might take
and give us some at least some examples
like you know if I violate it because
I'm breaking and I'm not sure obviously
that's a much lower could you move up
that scale to to ultimately dismissal
sure so um in our code of conduct we
have generally two forms of resolution
which is a conference or a hearing and
the vast majority of our
disciplinary proceedings are resolved
through a conference which tends to be a
one-on-one conversation with a staff
member U to put it in perspective we had
about 3,000 overall allegations last
year and only 80 of them resulted in a
hearing because the vast majority of
them are lower level violations that
happen in the residence Halls people
making too much noise students underage
drinking that we know are only going to
result in a warning or potentially um an
educational sanction that go with that
so in those lower level cases the basic
due process proceeding uh protections
that students are all afforded is right
to notice to have a notice of the
allegations uh they right to have a
meaningful opportunity to respond before
any uh final decisions are made um the
right to be to have an impartial
decision maker make those decisions
anything you would add
Alexis and then when we start talking
about a hearing which we use when a
student is going to be suspended a
potentially suspended potentially
dismissed um or more serious sanctions
then we have far more due process
protections that include what is in the
bill and Beyond including things like a
live hearing a panel hearing the right
to an advisor um more uh specified
timelines of notice and resolution and
and the
like sure so when um an activity occurs
at the fraternity house off campus that
we spoke to earlier and the allegation
was made to the university
itself and contact was then made with
the Durham Police where's the due
process in this thing is it now due
process according to your policy or is
it due process according to what the
city of Durham has got in place so the
two would be two separate processes
right if the town of Durham if there's
any criminal proceedings then they would
have their own separate processes if I
think what you're describing is we might
be no notified by the Durham Police
Department that for example a fraternity
house was very loud or well I take it
the university
notified the police in dur sure so now
we have it going that way where's due
process exist here is it now out of the
baileywick of unh I see what you're
saying in that of the town so if by us
notifying the police department we're
not seeding our right to follow up and
normally for the similarly to student
organizations the process will depend on
the potential sanction similarly most
sanctions are going to be informal
conversations or Warnings and those are
really handled by the governing bodies
that have been referenced throughout
this uh meeting today the inly council
or the panh helenic council those are
student governing bodies that part of
their role is to respond to these
allegations so we would share the police
report for example or the complaint with
the respective governing body who will
then work to resolve it based on the
their bylaws if the organization was
facing potential suspension or loss of
recognition then we would Implement a
different process that had more
procedural protections managed by the
office of community
standards I don't think my my question
was really answered oh no
okay I'm I'm if it's now in the hands of
the Police Department then they initiate
something through the court
system where's where's the due
process first of all how do how do how
does the attorney even know who made the
allegation and it seems to me there
there's there's a hole here in terms of
following and not I'm not following
along if if everything occurred
underneath Paul Dean's right right
Bailey work I could get it but I'm not
getting it now when we involve in you
know the the town of Durham coming in
saying you're too loud on this
fraternity MH and by the way we don't
have an ordinance on it but you're just
too
loud so it might speak to what I was
describing earlier with the amendment
that the the criminal proceedings and
the university proceedings are really
two parallel processes that could occur
simultaneously it's not common that we
would the ones to notify the police
maybe a student walked by the house and
called the police because they thought
it was too loud but more commonly we
would hear about an issue from the
police and anytime we're talking about
the university proceeding the D process
protections that I was describing apply
it would be managed depending on the
severity by the appropriate body most of
the time that's the governing body the
in fraternity Council the panh helenic
council whose due process procedure are
described in their bylaws and voted on
by the the respective Council so those
are the pro those are the protections
that would apply the the process that's
handled by the court system if there is
some separate court process that would
be totally separate from us um we would
move with our own proceedings following
our either our bylaws or our code of
conduct um and affording students all
the protections outlined therein thank
you sure are there any questions for
further questions from the committee for
Mike or Alexis
thank you very much does the University
cin I have attorney here that wants to
speak to this thing I'm looking right at
him no
um have few attorne yeah I yes I think
you have heard at this point as long as
bike and Alex are all sick I think those
are are the main concerns from our side
be happy to see Shan in the community
college system yeah that's where I want
to go next Shannon what what do you have
for us oh you have represent wait Alexis
and Mike oh is this a question for from
representative Damon there's a question
thank you Mr chair sorry little slow on
the
organization
um is there a communication process if
um there are criminal proceedings
against the student so through Durham
PD is there any formality of
communicating that to
campus meaning if the Durham Police
Department is working on some kind of
criminal proceeding do they
automatically notify us of that that is
the question yes uh not necessarily it
would depend on the nature of the
violation um but as I said earlier we
often will receive what we call landlord
notifications if a certain house or
property is too loud but there's no
automatic we get notified of every
criminal proceeding that's happening in
the town of Durham by law enforcement
thank you thank you very much thank you
thank
you
good afternoon I'm Shannon Reed here on
behalf of the community college system
I'm going to be brief because you've
already heard a lot about what I think
concerns that we share um about some of
the specifics of this bill and more
broadly while I I think the bill is
certainly very well-intentioned
um I think that it might have been
brought without an understanding of the
fact that we have very sound robust
policies already in place that I think
accomplish what the sponsors uh in in um
conceptually would want us to have um I
I think a lot of what you heard from the
University system is congruent with what
we experienced except of course we don't
have the Greek life component that you
heard you heard a story about um at the
outset I do have two colleagues here
with me from one from HR and uh CBA
negotiation and one from student
services who I will ask to follow me and
and address any kind of specifics that
pertain more to our system than what you
heard previously from our friends at the
University system but a couple things
that I'll that I'll point out that um we
still would have concerns or questions
about um before we'd be comfortable with
anything like this going
forward um first I think we pointed out
in the hearing this bill from the
employee standpoint includes faculty but
not staff so that would set up a kind of
a separate um process for staff and
faculty not that I want to suggest
expanding the scope of this bill but
just pointing out that it would set up
that kind of dual um structure so what
staff staff faculty got definition for
each yes we do not I mean basically
people who don't teach I mean I'm staff
um CHC Rubenstein is Staff people don't
teach you know our regist our bursters
our financial aid counselors our
admissions officers anyone like
that
um one concern I heard internally when I
talked about this bill with some of my
colleagues pertains to the the hearings
as they are outlined in house B 1288 um
the bill allows a respondent to
cross-examine a
complainant basically that the languages
confront and cross-examine Witnesses
um the bill doesn't set out what legal
guard rails would apply in that type of
a situation for example um would this
include
um should would this include uh Guidance
with respect to relevant lines of
questioning for instance sexual history
in a in a criminal trial there are very
clear guidelines understood by other
parties about what can and cannot be
asked I don't know that this bill
provides that type of guidance while it
allows for that same kind of format of a
hearing um and in fact allowing the
complainant to be the one to
cross-examine potentially I mean I'm
sorry allowing the respondent
potentially be cross-examining the
complainant um raises some concerns
about whether that could ret traumatize
the complainant in certain
situations I would also s um I do want
to raise the fact that the definition of
student in this bill and this is
something that could be tweaked but for
us we believe that that would probably
include all of our dual and concurrent
enrollment students these are high
school students who do fall under the
definition I think in this bill of
student so I I think that we would be
really cautious about opening up this
bill to a large high school student
population I just don't know what that
would look like in
practice and I will I will stop here and
see if there's any questions that I can
answer but I would also um after that
ask my colleagues to come up and speak
specifically about our CBA environment
HR environment and then the student
Affair
side repan
luno thank thank you very much Mr chair
and thank you very much Miss Reed for
taking my question um sort of similar to
um to what the university system spoke
to in terms of the number of complaints
they get um in a year and then leading
to a certain number of hearings and and
and disciplinary action I was wondering
if you could put that into the cont in
similar context but in in the in the
community college Quan context and yeah
and also maybe maybe also talk about any
sort of complaint
that that um community colleges have
received with respect to the processes
that you have in place today yeah thank
you for that question I I think that
that's best answered by my colleagues
who deal specifically with with this as
a part of their normal their normal work
thank
you further questions Shannon we're
talking Community College has older
adults in it but you do have these
minors do you have separate you know
Minor by meaning High School skids do
you have have a process to deal with
them by policy that are going through
issues maybe or
not well
any legal limitations that surround
their that adhere to their status as
minors we would of course need to follow
yeah I'm not sure if I'm really
answering your question um most of the
minors that we serve are those dual and
concurrent enrollment students we do
have some students who are legitimately
minors on our campuses I think any any
college would if you're if you're 18 I
think both of my kids started college
when they were 18 so I mean 17 um but if
you're asking specifically about the
Dual and concurrent enrollment students
um
we they they remain high school students
and so I'm not sure about the how it
would work in practice to have the
provisions of this bill potentially
apply to
them well I was thinking more you'd the
high school from where they're
from I'm sorry can you if there's an
issue with a dual concurrent situation
wouldn't you work with the high school
the sending
school or not I'm sorry I'm not sure I
can answer that question okay yeah thank
you thank you Shannon so I'd like to ask
Sarah Sawyer our director of human
resources and Megan Khan who is the um
vice president of student affairs at
Manchester Community College to come up
and fill in any gaps that I've left or
answer any specific questions that you
might have thank
you I'll let you go first
okay good afternoon um I'm Sarah Sawyer
I serve as the Director of Human
Resources for the community college
system of New Hampshire uh and in that
role am involved in collective
bargaining uh the community college
system as you know is comprised of seven
uh colleges across the state we also
have a system office which is really a
centralized uh business function uh we
currently have three covered uh
bargaining units uh a full-time faculty
bargaining unit an adjunct faculty
bargaining unit and a staff bargaining
unit um in each of our bargaining
agreements uh we have a due process that
has been negotiated uh between the
parties uh similar to the university
system we a progressive disciplinary
system um also as public employees
public employees certainly have a
element a significant element of due
process which includes uh anytime we're
engaging in any form of conversation
with regards to uh some form of what
I'll call disciplinary action that
includes a pre-meeting where we're
meeting with the employee we're
reviewing uh the concerns we're asking
for input from the employee and taking
all of that information into
consideration before we render any form
of
sanction um I would be happy to answer
any questions that you might have with
regards to our due process um I would
note that in our negotiated due process
not only does it include grievance
processes where an employee has the
right to bring forth their concerns that
progresses through a higher level of
management within the organization a
final step is what is an arbitration
process where that is an independent
third party reviewing uh the
circumstances and renders a decision
which is final and
binding thank you questions from the
committee yes represent Miler thank you
and thank you for being here um I'll ask
you the same questions I asked UNH what
is the what would be the impact of 1288
on your Collective bargain and agreement
um I share the view of my colleagues at
the University system and that uh it's
an adversarial approach um a couple of
things that uh that have caused me to be
concerned uh one is the uh hearing
nature uh certainly where
ultimately uh a respondent has the
opportunity to question a complainant it
it could create again a whole series of
negative experiences especially if the
situation was
traumatic um
and
also when as an employer if we're taking
an action against an
employee uh it is Management's
responsibility to ensure that they have
given due consideration for all of the
facts before them um employees still
have rights that go beyond ultimately a
grievance process or an arbitration
process um to hold management
accountable um so those are those are my
concerns and and we work similar again
to colleagues at the University system
um we put every effort in to try to
resolve issues at what we've referred to
as the lowest possible level and that
means having conversations with our
employees um taking opportunities to
create an environment with our employees
where uh circumstances that may have led
to an improper decision uh that there
may be ways to remedy that and to learn
from
those follow please yeah followup
273a gives the right of the employees to
organize and and negotiate their
contract um and so my concern is uh how
does this when it particularly when it
relates to staff
Etc does this would it would just
subvert that right of the employee to
have a discipline proc
process or a due process system that's
in the collective bargaining agreement
would would this subvert that effort
that would be the concern that I would
have um to some degree I think the other
concern point is the lack of of uh I
guess time frames and and timelines um
again we work um very um judiciously to
uh resolve issues but also Al to um
accommodate defined timelines that we've
negotiated
so uh c a question on as the bill was
introduced on page two says in all
disciplinary proceedings against a
student student organization or faculty
member the student student organization
or faculty member shall be entitled to a
hearing under published procedures that
include at a minimum all the following
and all the rights are listed underneath
the bill the right to this the right to
that um are you supportive of those
rights um I believe our process provides
those rights um we provide individuals
when we're taking action with the
determinations for whatever action that
is so we're providing them with the for
lack of a better term evidence we're
providing them with the opportunity to
refute that evidence um however um
ultimately the
what pauses me concerned is that hearing
process um the the timely timeliness
associated with that um the lack of of I
guess framework or guards surrounding
that process um but as public employees
uh I believe that we work very hard to
ensure that any action that we are
taking that ultimately the employee
understands understands the evidence
that we're using to take that action and
has the opportunity to refute that thank
you further questions from the
committee thank you very
much go ahead sorry Oh I thought you
working on tand go ahead so I'm Megan KH
and I'm the vice president of students
and Community Development at Manchester
Community College so I can speak to the
student experience at ccsnh in the
community colleges a little bit and
echoing what folks have said today I
think that our student Judiciary process
is absolutely laid out to provide the
student with every instance of um
support they need of their ability to
advocate for themselves their ability to
hear why they're in this situation what
has happened and in fact the way that
our student Judiciary process is written
is really specifically around that idea
of educating the student on what
happened and why it was not helpful or
why it went against our code of conduct
or why they're now in this trouble and
helping them become a productive member
of our community again so it really is
all built around this idea of welcoming
them back to be a member of the
Community College systems and I just
wanted to read a couple of those
highlights so this is built into what
our student conduct policy is um it's to
protect the relative rights of all
students adjudicate student behavioral
problems in an effective Equitable and
educational manner so again built around
around educating with those students why
their behavior wasn't considered
appropriate and then really specifically
enabling students to learn from their
experiences to foresee consequences of
the behavior and to avoid behaviors that
would violate ethical and moral
standards the missions of the college's
Judicial System shall be educational and
emphasis so we really think that we have
these things in place to support our
students who are going through the
Judiciary System like my colleagues at
the University system have said we have
many different steps and the majority of
ours are settled at a much lower
standard so I know there was a question
regarding kind of the number of incid
incidences that we deal with and I don't
have it for the full system I can say
that I've been with ccsnh for 10 years
five I've been very intimately involved
in the student Judiciary contuct and
there have not been a substantial number
of cases that have gotten to where we're
talking about removing a student from
their educational experience it's very
important to us at the community college
that everybody has that opportunity to
maintain their educational opportunities
at the community college system so
that's what we're working on how do we
allow everyone to have access um and I
will say that I think I think another
question uh was brought up about do we
have complaints about our process so for
the students at ccsnh they can appeal
they have an appeals process if they
don't like the decision and one of the
reasons they can appeal is because they
feel like their um their process was not
fair they feel like there was something
wrong with with a process they didn't
get notified at the right time they
didn't get to respond something like
that that's one of the basis is they can
submit an appeal and we will go through
the whole appeals process with them so I
think that speaks to um they have a way
to voice their concerns or complaints if
they have them um and again that is
really about bringing them back into
that educational setting um and and I
think the other question somebody asked
about oh the underage students so the
high school students uh for students
that are doing old who would be taking
the classes at their local high school
in most cases we allow this the high
schools would take the lead on the
Judiciary um actions or any code of
conduct however I think the concern here
is that this bill would require us to
then step in and and do things um in a
different way than maybe the high
schools are set up to do so it really
puts a double layer of um proceedings on
the student when in most cases I think
right now we are really set up to allow
students to be heard
in their home institution whether that's
the high school or the college um so
those were just a couple of questions I
had jotted down um that I hope I
answered for you if you remember that
but anything about the student process
at ccsnh or the community colleges um
I'd be glad to to talk about thank you
thank you very much represent Miler
thank you thank you for your testimony
uh we heard from the UNH that there are
multiple or at least my interpretation
what was said there are
multiple uh student Judiciary governance
issues around campus so that you're
dealing with kind of a peer and peer
review of a particular problem is there
a similar kind of a situation that you
have in the CCN SNH system so the
majority of our um concerns or potential
code of conduct complaints are going to
be handled at that conversation level um
it really can be split into either
something that's a violation of the
student conduct or something that it's
an academic violation so if it's
academic it's plagiarism it's something
in the classroom that's taken care of by
academic Affairs and the faculty and
there there's that process if it's the
student affairs it really starts with
did you know this is the policy what
happened where like what can you talk us
through the situation where is this
going if it escalates to a hearing we do
we can pull together a hearing board and
then an appeal board as well but very
few times is it more than that
conversation with the student to
say this is not acceptable behavior in
this situation and the sanction is just
a now you know we've talked about it now
you know that this isn't you know
constructive or this is against the code
of conduct um and it's not a removal of
it's not removing students from class
it's not removing students uh we're
fortunate the majority of us don't have
dorms so we're not talking about dorm
life we're not there's there's some who
do but for the majority of us it's more
of a when you're a member of this
community and you're here on Camp these
are the things that we look for so so
yeah so thank you so is the conversation
that you're just related to is that
staff to student or is there student to
student um so it's usually not student
to student unless for some reason it was
it happened in a club meeting we do
teach students to advocate for
themselves so you know we've had
situations where a student was in a club
meeting and said something and another
student in that club meeting felt
uncomfortable and they might come report
that student and our conversation is
have you guys talked about what the
roles of your Club is what's the norm
for your club meetings have you had
conversations about what is and is not
appropriate is it just Club business or
are you allowed to hang out and talk
about what you did on the weekends have
you guys talked about what is a comfort
level that you guys are willing to
discuss are you comfortable calling each
other out so we'll coach the students on
having those and if they're not
comfortable then we absolutely have
someone from student life or a staff
member um or a faculty adviser help them
with those conversations
thank you very much are further
questions from the committee thank you
very
much represent Len did you have a a a
concern or a
question
yeah I saw you moving around there like
you yes go come on
yes
so
the I guess my the the the basic point
that I would make is I think it's really
important to recognize that one of the
provisions I don't have the bill right
in front of me now I just have the
amendment but one of the provisions in
the bill I believe says that um there's
uh any institution that's covered by
this bill is is perfect it's perfectly
proper for them to to have processes in
place that provide more due process
protection than this bill what they
can't do is provide less and so I have
to I mean I guess one of the things I
would I would ask you to think about is
the various OB if if the processes that
the community college system and the
university system have talked about are
the equivalent of or better than what's
in this bill what's the problem they can
continue to use them it seems like
they're what they're really saying is
you know there's well maybe we don't
quite provide the due process protection
that the Bill calls for and that's what
we're worried about um the only and I
give you an example the only specific
thing that I heard anybody talk about
was the time limits maybe there are some
time limits in this bill that are
different than um than are than the time
limits in some collective bargaining
agreement or other you know if that's
the issue if it should be fit you know
two weeks instead of one week or what
change that I I if you know maybe I I I
certainly am not married in any sense to
the specific time limits if it if
there's an argument that you know uh the
time limit should be a little greater or
whatever um fine make th make those
changes um the uh the other point that
that I would make is first of all let me
just let me make two other points first
with regard to why does this bill refer
only to faculty and students or student
organizations and not staff
candidly uh in drafting the bill my
concern was some of the things that have
been going
on uh where you know uh where people it
just seemed uh and I'm talking generally
around the country where it just seemed
that people students or faculty members
were being treated unfairly uh political
correctness was sort of the you know the
reigning philosophy and it seemed to me
that that the people that were uh were
likely the targets of that were faculty
members and students I I hadn't really
heard much about staff and so that's why
you know but but again if the if it
should apply to everybody if there's a
concern that we shouldn't have two
system put staff in I don't I would not
have any problem with that I just sort
of you know I tried to focus on what I
thought um was the problem um the other
point that I would ask you again to
think about on this regard is this um
you've heard from the various
University people from the community
college system and the university system
um if this was such a bad thing
for faculty and staff and unions where
are those people how come they're not
how come you haven't had any Union
person in here saying this is terrible
don't do this to us um this is a you
know you're you're taking away our
rights I haven't heard that and I
suspect that that might be that you know
maybe they don't think this is so bad or
at least they're at least they're
thinking that the that um they would
have the the the the rights that are G
granted under their collective
bargaining agreement would be the
collect would be would be equivalent and
there'd be no problem they can continue
to follow what's provided under their
collective bargaining agreements so I
guess
those uh
are some of the things that I would that
I would ask you to think about the last
point that I would make is it you know
it it says in the in the definition of
disciplinary proceeding disciplinary
proceeding means an action or proceeding
instituted I don't think that the you
know to the extent that there was this
uh the the concerns raised about well we
you know we have a collaborative process
we first try to talk to someone um I
don't see how that
is how anything in this interferes with
that that's not the beginning of a of a
uh of a proceeding to suspend someone
that's I mean I guess the equivalent
would be in the uh in the uh you know in
the criminal law context if a policeman
walks up to you and and and starts to
talk to you um raising some some
question about you know I you know I'm
not quite sure why you're in this area
what you're doing that doesn't start a
criminal proced meeting if they issue
you some kind of a ticket or whatever or
they arrest you obviously but if they
issue you some kind of a some kind of a
ticket that starts a proceeding so I
don't see how any of the I mean I think
the idea that the col the collaborative
process that they're talking about that
all sounds fine to me and I don't see
how anything in this Pro in this is in
any way inconsistent with that so anyway
that's that's uh thank
you R Miler yeah thank you I you know I
guess I go back to why was this filed I
mean was there an incident was there uh
history I mean we we've heard from OB
obviously we've heard the institutional
voice there's no question about that
sure and so I I mean we we we this is
dealing with due process we've heard
there's collective bargaining there's a
grievance procedures an arbitration
procedure there's student uh there's
student reviews of issues why why was
this brought forward was was there
something that initiated this or was
just or was this just a philosophic
issues that I think this would be good
to have right so can you clarify for me
sure no I think I mean I think that as I
said before I think the the the issue
that prompts this is the kind of things
that we've seen going on around the
country with you know uh faculty members
or students or student organizations
being kind of cancelled um uh and and
things that we've seen um uh you know
coming out of um first the the Obama
Administration then it was canceled
under the Trump Administration and now
apparently there at least some some uh
effort to restore it uh in the Biden
administration of uh you know kind of
cutting back on the uh the processes
that are fored students who were accused
and I you know I can't help I can't help
notice that one of the prior people who
spoke to you just a few moments ago
talked about a concern about well if we
allow
cross-examination uh uh a complainant
might be
traumatized well you know that uh is
that a legitimate concern yeah but I
didn't I didn't hear her say that we
should be concerned about whether
somebody had been improperly accused and
didn't have the the the the the right to
cross-examine to basically assert
establish that he was that he was
innocent
so you know it's and I don't please
understand I don't fault the prior
witness for that at all traum
traumatization of of uh of of uh victim
is certainly a legitimate concern but I
think you know it's a two-way street and
and part of the the fact that you focus
on traumatization of the victim uh but
don't sort of consider the other side of
the equation that's the problem I think
that that is why this kind of this kind
of uh legislation is needed because
there are you know from from 27 years of
serving as a judge there are two sides
to the story um and and you have to be
concerned with both sides of the story
just as a followup believe me if I've
learned anything in my life that is
there are two sides of every story and
you need to know both both sides I
understand that but you talk about a
national culture that you're concerned
with in this state are there issues that
prompted this piece of legislation as a
result of actions that have been taken
by the University or whatever in this
state I you know I can't I can tell you
that I have heard sort of General kind
of complaints but I can't give you a
specific like this happened on this date
no I cannot give you that thank you very
much yes representa
Tanner thank you um I worked briefly in
a college um as a Adjunct
professor and I was in the wellness I
taught wellness and health and um one of
the most delicate issues that comes up
at colleges I in my opinion is sexual
assault and I kind of think it's the
hidden elephant in the room today uh
that we're talking around that when you
talk about Obama Trump Biden I think
you're talking about title n
um and I think you're talking about
sexual assault on campus um and I think
that that
uh that that the
general the general way it's handled at
colleges has to be very very delicate um
very delicate because a lot of times the
victim doesn't want to press
charges uh but obviously they
can't think can't just go on campus just
as they always have um and the person
who's the perpetrator sometimes is um
totally clueless not totally clueless
but um was drunk or uh really didn't
know have much training or anything on
consent um beforehand so I think when we
talk about
traumatizing victims through the
perpetrator or the person that's accused
cross-examining them I mean that would
be horrific in the case of sexual
assault and on most of the ca well at
least my understanding is that a lot of
campuses have specific guidelines set up
for sexual assault and specific uh ways
to deal with it um that this due process
um that you have in this bill would
really interfere with it and I I'm very
opposed to it thank you well I guess the
only I could say in respon
representative and I say this
respectfully but you know that
um the traumatization that you're
talking about um could could it exist
yes but I don't think that that what
follows from that is that we can we can
just assume that what if it didn't
happen what if the what if in fact the
person is innocent isn't that the reason
that you have cross-examination because
I mean that that's the whole point of
the of of you know our system we don't
you know we don't how how however much
we may feel for someone we don't we
don't say well we'll just you know the
victim must be believed that's I'm sorry
but that's just not true the victim you
know the victim may very well in many
cases be telling the truth and the and
the perpetrator should be punished I
have no doubt about that um but we can't
just assume that that's true because
there you know it may be the case that
the that the person that's accused is
innocent and should have an opportunity
to demonstrate that and that
cross-examination is you know from time
immemorial has been one of the one of
the you know ways in which that's done
is through is through cross-examination
so
yes so I I can't remember the exact
statistics but it's overwhelmingly that
most people who are victim of sexual
assault don't don't go to a criminal
level and the reason they don't go to a
criminal
level for well there's several reasons
they don't go to a criminal level but at
at when you're in your 20s or late
teens you know it whatever happens is
going to affect both those people both
parties tremendously for the rest of
their lives and so the more can be
handled at a local situation
um involving maybe even parents at that
level uh but certainly people who know
crisis centers who know how to handle it
um I think to then throw in due process
and criminal law you're just you're
you're making a bad situation unbearable
so that would be my point no I you know
I'm with you I I think I'm probably with
you 9 to 90% of the way but but where it
where I would draw the line is if that
you know sort of informal kind of we're
going to talk about it kind of
collaboratively if the bottom line of
that is the student is being s you know
here suspended if that's the bottom line
then it seems to me that that's that's
where the student the accused student
and obviously the student can wave any
of these there's no reason that I think
the bill specifically says that student
can wave a student or faculty member can
wave all of these things if he wants to
or she wants to but if they don't do
that and the bottom line is the students
going to be suspended it seems to me
that there is where the student has a
right to say wait a minute you know um
I've got I have some rights here too and
yes the rights are less than would be
the case in a criminal trial where proof
had to be Beyond A Reasonable Doubt and
it's a public trial and all that sure um
but to just say you
know you don't have any right to sort of
defend yourself
that I have a problem with that I I
don't think they ever say that they
don't have any could be a question sorry
okay um are there any other questions
for representative Lynn right
now represent thank you very much
representative papovich uh Muller you
you had your hand out extremely brief
okay thank you Mr chairman I just wanted
to be again extremely brief because you
know we spent a lot of time on this and
frankly I learned quite a few things
here I'm not a co-sponsor of this bill
but in my view one of the benefits of
this bill is that it would protect our
universities which currently are
required to conduct investigations with
standards that could result
in bad decisions and I uh while I was
waiting there and researching stuff I
just found a December 23 article in the
Philadelphia Inquirer about a $15
million award to a
doctor against Thomas Jefferson
University because of the outcome of a
title 9 investigation that was conducted
according to those rules resulted in an
incorrect decision and uh you know the
courts then created a massive Financial
liability against the university in
question right now universities have so
many rules on how quickly they have to
do things and how to do things creating
this clear legal standard at the state
level would give them a clear way to do
it which would also protect them against
those types of outcomes and I'd be happy
to send um you know link to that
particular article to uh you know the
committee just for your information so
you can review it I don't want to take a
lot of your time but I just wanted to
share that point of view on this Bill
thank you very much any questions from
the committee thank you yes
[Music]
Shannon I just just very briefly I feel
like I need to clarify um something that
I said said earlier were that the
sponsor alluded to and I I certainly did
not intend in any way to prioritize the
the rights or position of the
complainant over the respondent but my
my point was more in giving the uh
respondent the right in this bill to
confront and cross-examine um does that
does that respondent understand legal
guard rails that that would be in place
in a in a courtroom proceeding for
example what can be asked what can't be
asked what's what's kind of fair game
and what isn't um the right to
cross-examine the right to um explore
and interrogate the the information and
and whatever evidence has been brought
forth is certainly something that
happens in the context of our existing
um procedures and processes but it's not
the um kind of layman if you will who's
who's doing it it's someone who who
understands what those rules
are thank
you thank you very much is there anybody
else who wanted to speak on this bill
thank you so we're going to move on now
to the next bill which we had 1305 which
is freedom of speech and
Association at public institutions of
higher
education
yep thank you Mr chair I really have a
very short um statement to make
basically two two things one is that
um during the initial hearings I was
under the impression because the bill
had an extension that it was a two
committee bill I learned later what the
committee already knows that it is a
single committee Bill I just wanted to
correct that misstatement on the record
since I misspoke the first time not
knowing what the situation was the other
thing that I wanted to share was
that excuse me I did spend time talking
to the um Office of the civil rights of
the Attorney General and we were able to
agree on language that would um address
the concerns they expressed um as as
feedback to the bill that amendment has
been filed withs I I hope it will be
ready by the end of tomorrow and as soon
as it is ready I will share it to the
committee other than that I'm just here
to be available if anybody has questions
I don't have a lot of U statements to
make thank you very much yeah when you
get a hold of that representative can
you make sure it gets as soon as the OLS
has it and ask for it to be done by
tomorrow the yeah and can they send the
house committee Services right upstairs
and it'll be disseminated to the I will
make sure that as soon as there it will
be sent to everybody thank you thank you
very much does there anybody like to
speak on the freedom of speech freedom
of association
bill
yes I I'll be very very brief since I
talked to and at you about this at at
enormous length first of all I just want
to say I want to thank um representative
Papa M for working with the Attorney
General's office on the definition of
harassment that was one of our concerns
uh we'll look to see what comes out but
we just want to say publicly thank you
to the representative for having done
that um and uh beyond that the other
challenges that we've identified sort of
still remain we're happy to answer
questions about any of them the one
point we haven't made in a while um and
before and I just want to raise again
now is um we've just had an extensive
discussion about that last bill two
process this bill has now been heard U
at public hearing twice in two years and
the study session
um if you add it all up the combined
time of the committee that's been put
into the bill is I it's going to be 60
odd hours at this point um on this bill
and I think one of the things you're
understanding is it's challenging to
find the right way to strike the balance
on these things because once you drill
down to these issues that affect kind of
low-level University operational things
like how do we manage our student clubs
and how do we issue permits um they're
kind of getting down into the weeds and
I would suggest that if you look at uh
187a um the legislature a long time ago
made a statement that in general it's
going to leave those issues to the Board
of Trustees of the University system and
I think it does it for two reasons one
is because um I know if we express some
concern I've heard concerns from from
the sponsor about how well the people
running UNH change all the time so the
people running the state change
sometimes too and it's hard for us to
respond to the competing calls but the
other part of it is this is one very
small part of the University's
Administration and this committee has
already had to SN a lot of hours of its
time into it and I think that's why the
legislature those many decades ago made
the decision that they're going to
offload a lot of that to the Board of
Trustees and I think if the if the
committee decided that it was going to
rest on that decision that the
legislature made that time ago to leave
these sorts of matters to the Board of
Trustees it would be consistent with how
it's treated similar matters in the past
and now I will genuinely be quiet and
stop saying a single more word about
this bill unless
asked questions from the committee uh in
the last several months college campus
has gone through a a lot of difficult
times dealing with freedom of
speech however it's been fairly settled
at UNH can you tell me
why I think it's a combination of things
um one is I you heard from Chief Dean uh
when he was here to testify I think he
and his team do a very good job of
working with events on campus to make
sure that people get heard but that
things sort of stay people caller inside
the lines the other part and this is
down partially the person in the seat I
will admit but there's been a real
institutional commitment to it um going
back a number of years now um right down
to working with fire to rewrite all of
our policies to make sure that they
lined up with what fire was hoping to
see um and so I think what you're seeing
is the outcome of a commitment to
creating policies and practices that
facilitate speech without about
minimizing disruption and honestly
willingness by the Board of Trustees and
the administration to um withstand the
pressure that comes from folks who are
unhappy when speech happens they
disagree
with thank you any further questions
from the
committee n see thank you very much is
there anybody else sitting here that
would like to speak today regarding this
bill
1305 yes represent
beler
Tom were you pointing to I thought you
pointing to C Miss prenter
okay okay thank you Mr chair members of
the committee for the record uh
representative Mike beler Carol District
4 um so we were we were here and we
heard our the original testimony on this
bill during the hearing we heard from a
student who was a member of a
conservative oriented student
organization who participated in a
two-person tabling event that was not
permanent uh he testified that the event
was shut down by the university when the
university testified we did in fact
learn that this was their policy that
any unper events um are not allowed to
go forward that you require to get a
permanent headed time for these events
as a part of that uh hearing I requested
information I received information the
database of permits issued for
2023 um in this per in this database I
identifi one event that was not
permitted yet it was nonetheless allowed
to go forward it was a rather large
event uh it was in the tragic aftermath
of the shooting in Lewiston um but this
again this is an unpent event that was
allowed to go forward uh despite not
having received pyro approval we've
heard other testimony to that effect in
this committee as well uh further in
this database there were six um out of
the hundreds of permits issued there
were six permits indicating um that uh
amplification of sound was requested of
those six four were requested by
Evangelical Christian organizations and
two requested by uh Pro Palestinian
organizations of the Evangelical
Christian organizations all four were
denied one of the two uh prop
Palestinian were approved um they may
make the case that this was they were
concerned about um some sort of
disturbance however I would note that
the second uh uh event that was approved
it was the prop Palestinian protest that
was approved for amplication
amplification despite the fact that a
prior event of the same sort had
resulted in considerable controversy and
a rebuke from the governor even now
that's not my concern as far as free
speech goes I think free speech is Free
Speech but it very seriously undermines
any argument that the other
organizations were denied
amplification because they were afraid
of disruption lastly there was another
event um the only event in the entire
database that I discovered covered uh
that required extra scrutiny because to
the extent that they had to consult with
a detective on the force about it
because apparently it had received um
complaints from students uh this as well
was a conservative uh Christian
organization looking to do Evangel U
evangelism on
campus um and this again is despite the
fact that there were Untold numbers of
events uh labeled um
sex toy popup demonstrations that
apparently required absolutely no extra
scrutiny to approve so it would be my um
belief that this database that I I
believe I provided previously um
contains incontrovertible evidence of
viewpoint based discrimination at UNH
despite their fire record being good at
the
moment thank you thank you are there
questions of the
representative
thank you very much thank
you um Mr
Cronin
yeah good afternoon again Tom cron with
the university system uh so thanks to
representative beler uh for pointing
some of those out I just thought it'd be
helpful to respond as we discussed in
the last year and two sides to every
story um during the hearing you heard
from a student who was working with
Americans for Prosperity who testified
that they were not given immediate
approval to set up a uh table to handout
literature I think you also recall that
student saying within 2 days they were
given approval to handout literature and
there are at least four occasions within
the permitting documents uh of Americans
for Prosperity being able to do exactly
what that student was asking for
Americans for Prosperity is at present
not a recognized student organization so
there are different rules that govern
when total third parties to the
university come to the university and
are given permission to hand out uh
evangelize as the the representative
spoke and other things but I think it's
pretty clear through here that once
asked uh the university is is very
forthcoming in terms of allowing outside
groups to share information with our
students amplification is a time place
and manner restriction which we've
talked about a lot within uh the context
of this bill the situations the
representative mentioned the one that
was approved that group specifically
moved from directly in front of Thompson
Hall folks who are famili with the
university know that is the m
administration building is right next to
our library and is right next to an
academic building they move from that
facility across the street into what we
call the Fishbowl at the University
which is a big open field at that point
they had removed themselves from the
place concern we have about allowing
amplification directly in front of
Thompson
Hall the event the representative
mentioned where there was additional
police scrutiny that group uh at
multiple times had complaints from
students of harassment a harassing
behavior on behalf of the folks who were
on campus handing out their literature
up to and including making physical
contact with students nevertheless after
having a conversation with the police we
allow them to come back and continue to
exercise the First Amendment rights I
think what this document shows is 2011
cases over the course of the last year
where organizations have wanted to
organize and we're given the permission
to wanted to assemble hand out
information on campus and we're given
the permission to do so so I'll stop
there be happy to take any questions
thank you very much are there any
questions thank thank you very
much is anybody else want does anybody
else want to speak with the subcommittee
right now if not I'm going to close this
subcommittee work we will uh due to the
fact that a number of people had to
leave today for other meetings we will
continue this prior taking action when
we exect the Bill thank you very
much
C